bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat cet après-midi les
sénateurs poursuivent l'examen du projet
de loi de finances pour 2013 ce matin
ils ont décidé de reporter de 2013 à
2016 l'application de la taxe générale
sur les activités polluantes pour les
départements d'outre maire cet
après-midi une large partie des
discussions va être consacrée à la
question de l'impôt sur les sociétés la
droite sénatoriale dénonce une pression
fiscale accrue sur les sociétés et
entend bien s'opposer aux propositions
du gouvernement en la matière tout de
suite donc direction l'hémicycle du
Sénat poursivre cette séance bon
après-midi à tous la séance est reprise
nous reprenons la suite de la discussion
du projet de loi de finance pour 2013
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale dans la
discussion des articles nous sommes par
parvenu à l'amendement un numéro 150
rectifié tendant à insérer un article
additionnel après l'article
15 donc je suis saisi d'un amendement
numéro 150 présenté par Monsieur
bequet bien monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues adopté par le Sénat l'an
dernier à pareille époque sur
proposition de Madame Nicole brick
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances cet amendement nous semble
particulièrement bienvenu en ces temps
particulièrement difficile pour les
comptes publics je me permettrais ici de
citer les termes exacts employés par
notre ex-collègue pour exposer les
motifs de son intéressante proposition C
amendement vise à encadrer les règles de
neutralisation des codes part pour frais
et charges dans le régime de
l'intégration fiscale et donc à
restreindre l'emploi d'un avantage non
justifié de ce régime il suite en cela
une recommandation de la Cour des
comptes laquelle elle estime que
certains avantages outrepassent la
simple compensation des résultats
bénéficiaires et déficitaires en l'état
actuel du droit du régime de
l'intégration fiscale ainsi les
transferts de dividendes sont considérés
comme des mouvements de trésorerie et ne
sont donc pas imposés or dans un autre
régime du groupe d' mèfille que nous
avons déjà évoqué les dividendes sont
imposées à hauteur de 5
%. par exemple une société qui reçoit 10
millions d'euros de dividendes d'une
filiale n'acquitera pas d'impôt sur les
sociétés sur ce montant dans le régime
de l'intégration fiscale tandis qu'elle
versera 160000 € dans le régime mère-
fille à mes yeux il convient de mettre
un terme à cet avantage inconsidéré en
outre cette mesure permettrait de faire
revenir au moins 1 milliard d'euros dans
les caises de l'État ce ne serait pas
inutile par les temps qui court sachant
que le régime de l'intégration fiscale
coûte chaque année près de 15,8
milliards d'euros aux finances public
fin de citation il y a me semble-t-il
des explications et des éléments déjà
fournis qui garde ici toute leur
pertinence nous ne pouvons qu'inviter le
Sénat à confirmer son vote d'il y a 1 an
en adoptant de nouveau cet amendement
tout à fait signifiant je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur boet quel est
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur
général cet amendement que vient de
présenter Éric beet à l'instant propose
de restreindre un avantage injustifié du
régime de l'intégration fiscale au
regard du régime merfi et euh comme il a
indiqué c'est quelque chose qui a déjà
été évoqué au Sénat et bien entendu je
peut difficilement être défavorable à
l'adoption de cet amendement puisque
l'an passé c'est Nicole brick mon
prédécesseur à ce poste qu'avait
présenté et le Sénat l'avait adopté
euh pour autant ce qu'il faut souligner
c'est que la configuration du budget
proposé pour 2013 s'appuie sur sur une
politique de prélèvements fiscaux à
l'égard des entreprises et des
particuliers qui a fait jouer d'autres
levier et aant fait jouer d'autres
leviers il y a effectivement la
perception d'une fiscalité additionnelle
relativement importante à l'égard des
entreprises qui provient d'autres
sources de mise en recouvrement
vis-à-vis des entreprises dans ces
conditions on a ici un gain qui est
supposé de l'ordre de 1 milliard d'euros
un peu plus
c'est
donc au regard de l'équilibrage global
de ces recettes sur les entreprise qu'il
faut analyser l'impact de cet amendement
et c'est en fonction de ce que le
gouvernement pourra nous dire à ce sujet
que la commission des finances a
souhaité se positionner puisque nous
avons souhaité avoir l'avis du
Gouvernement sur cet amendement
et cet avis monsieur le
ministre merci Monsieur le le président
oui monsieur le sénateur vous avez
raison de souligner que c'est une mesure
qui a été souvent proposée et défendue
vaillamment par les uns et par les
autres dans un contexte qui n'était pas
exactement celui que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui puisque entre ce moment où
ces amendements étaient déposés et
défendus au moins deux mesures sont
intervenues d'abord la suppression du
plafonnement de la côte part taxable de
frais et charges dans le régime merfille
et ensuite l'augmentation de 5 à 10 % de
la côte part de frais et charges
afférente au plus-value de cession de
titre de de participation ainsi que
l'article 14 du projet de loi qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure et qui consiste à prendre
en compte non plus les plusvalues nettes
mais les plusvalues brutes donc entre le
moment auquel vous avez fait référence
et je vous en remercie et l'instant de
notre débat trois dispositions ont été
envisagées deux ont été adoptées la
troisième je l'espère le sera lorsque ce
texte sera définitivement voter
et comparaison n'étant pas toujours
raison il s'avère
que si le Sénat le Parlement le cas
échéant adoptait la disposition que vous
préconisez alors je pense que les les
taxations sur les entreprises ne
deviendrai pas importantes ou lourde
ellees deviendrai probablement excessive
il faut se garder d'aller trop loin
savoir jusqu'où on peut aller trop loin
le gouvernement s'est efforcé d'avoir
des de retenir pardon des dispositions
équilibré avant de les proposer au
Parlement c'est cas du projet qu'il
dépose et si votre amendement était
retenu adopté ce que je ne souhaite pas
alors je pense que c'est l'économie
générale du texte qui serait compromis
et la taxation pour les entreprises
prendrait un tour que le gouvernement
jugerait excessif donc le gouvernement
appelle au rejet de cet
amendement bien je vais donc mettre au
voix cet
amendement l'amendement 150
rectifié un avis défavorable du
gouvernement qui est pour cet
amendement qui est
contre il n'est pas
adopté à l'article 16 je suis saisi de 6
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion
commune le prier est le 77 rectifié
présenté par Monsieur Collin oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le présent
amendement a pour objet d'exclure les du
dispositif durcissant les règles de
report des déficits prévu à l'article 16
le Rapporteur général a demandé en
commission le retrait du présent
amendement indiquant qu'il était
satisfait si tel est le cas monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterait que vous le
précisiez clairement devant nous car
notre présence sur le terrain nous a
permis de constater la très grande
inquiétude de nombre de petites et
moyennes entreprises à ce sujet
concernant la stratégie fiscale du
gouvernement de façon plus générale or
il nous semble monsieur le ministre
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de ce
PLF dont cell prévu à l'article 16 sont
conçu nous semble-t-il pour s'appliquer
uniquement aux grandes entreprises qui
peuvent contribuer à l'effort de
redressement mais sans mettre en péril
leurs activités les petites et moyennes
entreprises doivent quant à elle être
clairement soutenu leur développement
doit être encouragé car nous le sa avons
tous et vous plus que quiconque monsieur
le ministre notre croissance économique
souffre de l'absence d'un tissu
suffisamment solide d'entreprise de
taille dite intermédiaire il me semble
que le Gouvernement partage ce constat
d'ailleurs constat récemment rappelé par
l'excellent rapport Galois je vous
invite donc monsieur le ministre à nous
confirmer clairement avec cet amendement
le soutien de votre gouvernement aux PME
de notre de notre pays je vous remercie
je vous remerci chers collègu j'ai
ensuite deux amendements identiques dont
le premier le 42 n'est pas défendu donc
madame desé vous nous présentez le 125
oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je dirais que la deuxème loi
de finances rectificative pour 2011
avait plafonné le dispositif de report
en avant des déficits des entreprises
soumises à l'impôt sur les
sociétés l'article 16 en portant le taux
de 60 à 50 % diminue ce plafond ce qui a
pour conséquence de rendre le mécanisme
d'imputation des déficits plus
pénalisant pour les entreprises
françaises que celui appliqué en
Allemagne donc cet amendement propose
que cette baisse du plafond et un
caractère provisoire ce qui permettra
aux entreprises françaises de ne pas
altérer la présentation de leur compte
consolidé tout en participant pour 2 ans
à à l'effort
budgétaire madame desego pour
pouvez-vous nous présenter le 209
puisque le 43 rectifié ne peut être
défendu avec plaisir monsieur le
Président là toujours cet article 16
toujours en portant le taux de 60 à 50 %
diminue donc le plafond du déficit
reporté à avant imputable sur l'
exercice budgétaire et je note que cette
mesure s'appliquerait au résultat des
exercices ouverts à comptter de l'entrée
en vigueur de la présente loi
c'est-à-dire au résultat des exercices
ouverts à compté du 1er janvier 2012
c'est c'est véritablement un caractère
rétroactif de la mesure qui ajoute à
l'instabilité d' d'un dispositif adopté
il y a un an seulement ce qui quand même
particulièrement préjudiciable à la
sécurité juridique des des entreprises
donc cet amendement propose que la
mesure s'applique au résultats des
exercices ouverts à comptter du 1er
janvier 2013 je vous remercie chers
collègues le 62 est présenté par le
président
Marini président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues il est tout à fait
identique à l'amendement qui vient
d'être excellemment défendu par
Marie-Hélène desego et nous observons
d'ailleurs non seulement sur l'article
16 mais par exemple sur l'article 15 que
nous examinions en fin de matinée que le
gouvernement semble faire de la
rétroactivité un nouveau principe
d'action législative n'est-ce pas alors
que le contraire devrait être vrai et
nous voyons dans cette loi de finance
proliférer des dispositions
volontairement rétroactive et qui place
les agences économiques dans une
situation
imprévisible au moment où leurs
décisions ont pu être prises d'où cet
amendement
de
de rappel
et qui bien entendu poursuit les mêmes
objectifs que l'amendement
précédent bien donc monsieur le
rapporteur général pour la commission
sur le 6 17 rectifiés 125 et 209 et 62
qui sont quasiment identiques
oui c'est vrai monsieur le Président
donc effectivement le
77 a une forme d'originalité il propose
d'exempter les PME de l'application de
l'article 16 que nous examinons
s'agissant du régime des reports en
avant des déficits alors nous avons
examiné cette situation à la commission
des finances et il nous a semblé que
l'amendement était satisfait dans
l'esprit puisque le report en avant des
déficites ne subit aucune limitation
jusqu'à 1 million
d'euros ce seuil n'est pas modifié par
l'article 16
et vise justement à préserver les PME
donc si l'amendement est en fait
satisfait dans son esprit je pense que
il sera opportun de de pouvoir retirer
cet amendement me semble-t-il c'est ce
que vous suggère la commission des
finances en ce qui concerne les 42 et
euh il s'agit d'appliquer les
dispositions de l'article 16 pour les
seuls exercices clos entre 31 décembre
2012 et 2013 bon je suis bien sûr
défavorable à ces amendements il sera
possible à l'avenir de moduler le régime
de report en avant des déficites y
compris de manière plus favorable à
celui qui existe aujourd'hui et bien sûr
la priorité pour nous doit être le
redressement des finances publiques il
n'est donc pas opportun d'indiquer que
l'article 16 aurait un caractère
provisoire voilà et enfin s'agissant des
amendements 43 et 209 ainsi que celui
que Monsieur Marini vient à l'instant de
présenter qui est dans le même esprit il
s'agit de donc de de proposer de
reporter l'application reporter
l'application d'une année ce qui ferait
perdre 1 milliard d'euros pour le budget
2013 donc on dégrade le solde budgétaire
d'un milliard d'euros est souhaitable
bien sûr que non et j'ai le sentiment
monsieur le Président Marini que les
entreprises ayant été informées dès le
mois de septembre la fin du mois de
septembre de ce que l'on allait sans
doute trouver dans la loi de finances
2000 pour 2013 elles ont déjà une
information de de 3 mois et peuvent donc
intégrer dans leur perspective cette
cette évolution législation fiscale et
financière donc c'est un avis
défavorable tant
pour le report
que pour l'adaptation qui était prévu
dans les 42 et 40 et
125 monsieur le ministre quel est l'avis
du
Gouvernement merci Monsieur le le
président l'amendement que vous venez de
défendre monsieur le le sénateur est
intéressant mais je je pense qu'il est
satisfait dans la mesure où la la mesure
que prévoit cet article est de portée
générale et en élaborant en admettant
une franchise de 1 million d'euros je
crois permet au PME celle que vous
voulez défendre celle dont le sort nous
préoccupe permet au PME précisément de
ne pas avoir à pâtir de cette mesure qui
je le crois très objectivement ne
concernera que les plus grandes sociétés
certainement pas les PME c'est
d'ailleurs l'illustration de ce que l'on
a souvent indiqué à savoir que ces
dispositions qui sont rudes y compris
pour les ménages et certainement pour
les entreprises ces dispositions sont
demandées c'est ça sacrific sont demandé
aux entreprises qui disposent de la
marche pour les consentir sans
compromettre leur capacité
d'investissement et c'est parce que nous
ne voulions pas compromettre la capacité
d'investissement ou de gestion des
entreprises que cette franchise de 1
million d'euros a été élaborée je crois
donc que votre amendement est sans Oblet
si je peux me permettre cette expression
dès lors que l'article prévoit bien ce
cas qui évitera au PME d'être pénalisé
par cette disposition madame des égau
bon nous ne sommes pas dans la même
démarche l'opposition et et le
gouvernement nous souhaitons nous faire
participer les les grandes entreprise le
régime français de report en avant a été
comparé par vos soins avec le régime
allemand pour être complet il aurait
fallu également établir le parallèle
avec le régime d' report en arrière qui
est beaucoup plus favorable en France
qu'il ne l'est en Allemagne et dès lors
que l'on souhaite harmoniser avec notre
voisin alors il faut tout harmoniser il
nous semble que le régime que nous
proposons de report en avant combiné
avec les dispositions auquelles nous ne
touchons pas de report en arrière ce
régime là aboutit à un ensemble
équilibré par rapport à ce que font les
Allemands qui n'est pas rigoureusement
identique mais qui je crois se vaut donc
nous pensons pouvoir demander cela
c'est-à-dire cette réforme d'oports en
avant dès lors que nous ne touchons en
rien au report en arrière et comme vous
le savez C report en arrière sont très
favorables aux entreprises françaises
puisque ce report en arrière comprend
naturellement les les les années de
crise et très difficiles que les
entreprises ont pu connaître c'est un
régime qui leur est favorable et à ce
régime là nous ne touchons pas donc
j'appelle au rejet de votre
amendement monsieur le sénateur j'avais
suggéré le retrait du vôtre je ne l'ai
pas indiqué je le fais maintenant
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances regrette que la
rctroactivité apparaisse dans notre
droit fiscal ça n'est à mon avis
beaucoup moins d'une apparition qu'
s'agit que d'une affirmation puisque
dans la loi finances pour 2012 que vous
avez voté je le crois monsieur le
sénateur il y avait comme mesure
rétroactive la suppression de la pas
voter parce que c'était dans la version
de la majorité du Sénat je ne suis pas
certain mais je vais finir mon propos
parce que peut-être l'avez-vous voté
malgré tout car cette disposition dont
je m'apprête à parler est rentrée en
vigueur et donc j'ai du mal à imaginer
que la majorité de l'époque ne l'ai pas
voté n n'étions pas dans la majorité oui
mais vous étiez la majorité
gouvernementale donc je crois bien je
crois bien les compendu en frontfis les
contteendus en front fois mais il me
semble bien que vous avez voté la
suppression de l'abattement du tiers
pour les entreprises soumises à li dans
les départements d'outremè c'était
rétroactif vous avez approuvé le
duissement du régime fiscal des
redevances de brevet et des charges
déductibles afférent au produits de la
propriété industrielle de cela je suis
certain que vous l'avez approuvé c'était
rétroactif vous avez approuvé la
limitation de l'imputation des reports
déficitaires de cela aussi je suis
certain que vous l'avez voté c'était
naturellement rétroactif vous avez voté
la suppression me semble-t-il de Bénéfic
mondial consolidé c'était rétroactif
vous avez voté le rehaussement du taux
de la côte part pour frais et charge sur
plusvalue de session de titre de
participation on l'a vu tout à l'heure
je vous l'avais déjà rappelé vous l'avez
voté c'était rétroactif et enfin vous
avez voté la contribution exceptionnelle
sur la provision pour hausse de prix
constituée par les entreprises du
secteur pétrolier de cela aussi j'en ai
le souvenir vif la majorité
gouvernementale à laquelle vous
apparteniez l'avz voté bref six mesures
entrant en vigueur sur les exercices en
cours ont été voté en 2011 par les
parlementaire de la majorité
gouvernementale de l'époque qui semble
aujourd'hui regretter d'avoir fait œuvre
législative rétroactive et qui donc pour
manifester l'ampleur de ses regrets et
la
vivacité de leur contrition demande au
gouvernement de ne pas faire ce que
eux-mêmes ont fait mais monsieur le
Président nous faisons au moins sur la
méthode comme vous parce que comme vous
nous sommes soumis aux mêmes contraintte
et donc si je comprends votre argument
juridique je demande un tout petit peu
d'indulgence politique si c'est possible
donc
rejet
bien bien je vais par conséquent mettre
au voix
ah Monsieur Boquet
oui pas d'amendement pour notre part
quelques mots au nom du groupe CRC sur
l'ensemble des amendements et l'article
16 monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues peut-on
faire son marché dans la convergence
fiscale entre la France et l'Allemagne
en gardant ce qui séduit et en rejetant
ce qui ne plaît guerre c'est un peu ce
que font nos collègues de l'opposition
sénatoriale et notamment le président
Marini qui vient de s'exprimer ou en
rechignant devant l'application de
nouvelles règles relatives au reports en
avant comme en arrière des déficits ce
que les comptables nourrit au lait de
l'anglomanie appelle le carryback voilà
tout de même mes chers collègues un des
instruments principaux de l'optimisation
fiscale en matière d'impôt sur les
sociétés un jouet assez coûteux qui
prive l'État de plusieurs milliards
d'euros de ressources par an et qui fait
d'ailleurs du Trésor public une sorte de
guichet de banque des entreprises
assujetties à l'impôt sur les
sociétés on peut même considérer dans la
absolu que l'essentiel du décalage entre
impôt brut et impôt net perçu provient
de l'application de ces dispositifs je
souligne ici même que l'évaluation des
voies et moyens estime à 15,6 milliards
d'euros plus que le budget du travail et
de l'emploi ou que celui de la justice
par exemple ce décalage dont 13,9 au
seul titre des restitutions d'un compte
en trop perçu la mesure de l'article 16
est une pure mesure de trésorerie qui ne
change pas véritablement la nature de
l'impôt sur les sociétés et continue de
fait d'accepter la prise en compte de ce
qui peut parfois ne l'oublions jamais
procéder de la plus parfaite
optimisation fiscale le débat sur
l'article 15 a suffisamment montré qu'il
y avait moutes manières de placer une
entreprise dans une situation financière
incertaine notamment en transformant sa
marge d'exploitation en intérêt
financier versé à un créancier d'autant
plus gourmand qu'il s'agit parfois de la
société chapautant l'entreprise dans
cette affaire l'état fait donc fait donc
face à ces difficultés de trésorerie en
les faisant porter par les entreprise
dont il ne met pas en cause les choix de
gestion générateur de ces déficits
reportables je me demande bien ce que
nos collègues de l'opposition peuvent
trouver là de répréhensible à moins
qu'il ne préfère que nous émettions
encore un peu plus de dettes publiqu en
adoptant pas le dispositif de l'article
16 pour notre part nous ne voterons cet
article en
attendant ceci dit que nous fassions une
véritable expertise de l'absolu
pertinence du dispositif des reports en
arrière comme en avant des déficits dont
le coût important pour les finances
publiques plus de 20% du déficit
budgétaire de cette année est 0,7 points
de PIB environ et cependant parfaitement
réduite au regard des marges brutes
d'exploitation qu'est-ce donc en effet
que nos 13,9 milliards d'euros de
déficit reportable par rapport à 550
milliards d'euros de profit brut je vous
remerci bien je vous remercie chers
collègues je vais donc mettre au voix
monieur monsieur Collin
oui sur l'amendement euh vous l'aurez
compris monsieur monsieur le monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur général
le souci l'objectif de cet amendement
était d'attirer particulièrement votre
attention sur la situation des PME PMI
qui constituent le vivier fort de notre
économie et qu'il faut euh dans le souci
de de préserver au maximum donc c'était
pour attirer particulièrement votre
attention les réponses que vous avez euh
que n avez fourni tant celle de Monsieur
le rapporteur ur général que vous-même
semble nous satisfaire nous resterons
bien entendu vous le savez très vigilant
sur ces entreprises et je retire
l'amendement comme vous l'avez souhaité
donc l'amendement 77 rectifié est retiré
j'en viens donc maintenant au vote de
l'amendement 125 présenté par Madame
desego et qui a reçu un avis défavorable
et la Commission et du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté procédons maintenant au vote de
l'amendement 209 présenté par Madame
desego sachant que le 62 est identique
et voté en même temps ils ont reçu donc
un avis défavorable et de la Commission
et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient ils
ne sont pas
adoptésonsant au vote de l' article 16
qui est pour l'article
16 qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article 16 je suis saisi
d'un amendement numé
83 c'est Monsieur
Collin qui le présente
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègu si vous le
permettez monsieur le Président je
défendrai en mêmes les amendements 83 et
84 qui portent sur le même sujet sujet
que nous avons d'ailleurs déjà évoqué
lorsque j'ai défendu les amendements
après l'article 4
ququè si ce n'est que ces amendements
concernaient l'impôt sur le revenus et
donc les particuliers alors que les deux
précédents amendements
8384 portent sur les déductions d'impôts
accordés aux entreprises qui réalisent
des investissements outreemè ces niches
fiscales sont à la fois coûteuse pour le
gouvernement pour l'État et peu efficace
donc ont à mes yeux de défaut majeur
elles permettent surtout aux
contribuables aisés mais aussi aux
grandes entreprises de réduire le
montant de leur impôt ce qui est me
semble-t-il nous semble-t-il
parfaitement et profondément inéquitable
et d'ailleurs je soulligne que la Cour
des comptes a préconisé la suppression
de ces dépenses fiscales et c'est ce que
nous vous proposons d'ailleurs avec ces
deux amendements je vous remercie et je
vous propose de les adopter bien sûr
quel est l'avis de la commission sur
peut-être monsieur le rapporteur général
sur les deux sur les deux oui il
présenté les deux oui je pense quei oui
oui l'avis l'avis peut être donné
conjointement je souhaiterais que notre
collègue puisse retirer les deux
amendements parce que je rappelle que
les principales
dépenses fiscales sur impôt d'État en
faveur de l'outrem représentent un
montant de 3
milliards environ en 2013 soit bien plus
que les crédits de la mission outrem et
au fond ceci illustre une chose qui est
je crois évidente pour tous c'est que la
défiscalisation c'est le principal outil
utilisé par l'État pour favoriser le
développement de ces territoires donc
sur cette base- là il va soit qu'une
suppression brutal de ces dispositifs
aurait des conséquences très graves pour
l'autre maire certes comme l'a pointé la
Cour des comptes dans son rapport public
annuel de 2012 l'efficacité de ces
dispositifs mérite d'être examiné dans
le détail et c'est pour cette raison que
le ministre outremire Victorin Lurel a
annoncé que serait lancé très rapidement
une évaluation des dispositifs de
défiscalisation en faveur de l'outrem et
de même le gouvernement devrait remettre
au Parlement probablement au mois de mai
prochain un rapport étudiant la
possibilité et l'opportunité de
budgétiser ses aides fiscal pour qu'il y
ait une plus grande transparence et et
un regard donc circulaire du du
Parlement sur l'ensemble des dispositifs
et je pense donc qu'il serait plus sage
d'attendre de disposer de ces différents
rapports qui nous permettront de nous
prononcer en toute connaissance de cause
sur les dispositifs d'incitation fiscale
et dans ces conditions je suggère à nos
collègues le retrait de leurs
amendement monsieur le ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement sur ces deux
amendements
le gouvernement a le même avis monsieur
le sénateur que le rapporteur général on
a déjà eu l'occasion de s'en expliquer
on sait ce qui est la situation
aujourd'hui l'économie ultramarine est
financée par des dispositifs de
défiscalisation qui sont
incontestablement coûteux la chose n'est
pas
contestable ce qui en revanche pose
problème c'est la réelle efficience de
ces modalités de financement de
l'économie ultramarine ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point est
qu'aujourd'hui nous savons que ces
économies sont extrêmement fragiles et
dans une situation peut-être pire encore
que l'économie des entreprises
métropolitaines il a donc été décidé par
le gouvernement au regard de cette
fragilité de ne pas toucher aux
modalités de financement de l'économie
ultramarine c'est-à-dire de ne pas
modifier le régime de défiscalisation
outre mer pour 2013 tant il est vrai que
il faut avoir la main parfois hésitante
lorsqu'on touche au financement de
l'économie amarine car on sait les
conséquences que pourrait avoir des
décisions mal calibrées est-ce que pour
autant et au nom de ce prétexte qui je
crois est une bonne raison est-ce que
pour autant nous devons nous interdire
toute réflexion certainement pas et
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
rapporteur général y a fait allusion
avec mon collègue Victorin Lurel le
ministre des outres mers nous aurons en
2013 un travail approfondi transparent
auquel d'ailleurs les parlementaires qui
le souhaitent pourrait parfaitement
s'associer mais un travail euh je crois
abouti qui devrait permettre une fois
pour toute de déterminer si ce coût est
efficient ou s'il ne l'est pas s'il est
efficient le régime sera maintenu s'il
ne l'est pas il ne pourrait être
remplacé que par un régime d'aide à
l'économie ultramarine qui alors serait
d'une efficience supérieure qu'il
s'agisse de recalibrer le redéfinir
pardon le périmètre de l'aide fiscale ou
qu'il s'agisse de passer à une dépense
budgétaire don la vertu serait d'être
annuel permettant une évaluation
régulière et demandant au fond à l'état
d'assumer ses responsabilités sans
parfois donner trop l'impression de se
défausser un peu sur les années
suivantes renvoyant à l'investissement
privé défiscalisé le soin de remplir des
missions qui peuvent être considérées
comme des missions d'État voilà où nous
en sommes nous ne contestons pas qu'il
puisse y avoir interrogations nous les
avons mais nous estimons que ces
interrogations ne doivent pas déboucher
sur des mesure qui fragiliseraiit
considérablement l'économie ultramarine
au motif de financer celle-là dans des
conditions qui seraient peut-être plus
efficace et plus appréciable en
conséquence je reprends donc
l'argumentaire du rapporteur général
vous constaterez pour vous demander de
retirer cet amendement et le
gouvernement vous donne rendez-vous
l'année prochaine soit parce que nous
assumerons alors ces modalités de
financement soit parce que nous vous
proposerions en accord avec les les élus
de ces territoires bien évidemment nous
vous proposerion
d'autres modalités de financement
présentant les mêmes garanties de
pérenité et adapté aux besoins de cette
économie ultramarine sans que comme on
le sait trop aujourd'hui un certain
nombre
d'intermédiaires ne connaissent une
prospérité peut-être
suspecte et pas forcément au service de
l'intérêt général et trop souvent je le
crains au détriment de l'économie
ultramarine elle-même monsieur patient a
souhaité intervenir pour explication de
vote oui par ces amendements il est euh
purement et simplement demandé de
supprimer la défiscalisation dans les
autres mèes maintenue parce qu'elle est
justifiée par la situation économique et
sociale très difficile qui frappe ces
territoire en effet euh les économ3
marine font face à une situation sans
commune mesure avec les difficultés de
la métropole des taux de chômage qui
sont deux fois plus élevés un PIB par
habitant en revanche deux fois moins
élevé 16000 € dans les are ma cont 30000
€ en métropole un taux de couvertur des
importations qui ne dépasse pas 14 %
dans le meilleur des cas illustrant la
situation de dépendance dans laquelle
elle demeure enfermée enfin un accès au
crédit rendu difficile par des taux
beaucoup plus élevés qu'en
métropole l'urgence est donc tout autant
de préserver ce qui marche que
d'imaginer de nouvelles voies de
développement économique durable et
structurel on met souvent en avant les
abus et les dérives du système
plus rarement les réussites auxquelles
il a donné lieu or les bons exemples ne
manquent pas la défiscalisation a permis
un bon dans la production de logements
sociaux atteignant en 2011 7500
logements sociaux contre 5000 les années
antérieures l'installation des câbles de
communication électronique sous-marin en
Polynésie et en
Nouvelle-Calédonie la rentabilisation de
l'exploitation des dessertes aériennes
régionales aux Antilles à la Réunion en
Guyane les émergence de plateformes
logistiqu contribuant à la réduction des
coûts et à lutter contre la chireté de
la vie certes la défiscalisation
présente un coût pour l'État un cût qui
donne lieu à des chiffrages trop souvent
manquant de précision par exemple dans
un rapport l'IGF avance le chiffre de
4,8 milliards d'euros il ne faut pas
tout mélanger au risque d'encourager une
vision péjorative quartiris des
outremèes en fait ce montant additionn
le différentiel des taux de TV pratiqué
autreemè les exonérations de charges
social le dispositif de la TVA NPR et la
l'abattement sur le barê de l'impôt sur
le
revenu pour
2012 les dépenses sont estimées à un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros mais pas un
milliard d'euros pour les contribuables
les plus fortunés un milliard
d'euros dont une grosse partie est
rétrocéd aux exploitations des
équipements acquis grâce à l'éparne
mobilisée ce taux de rétrocession dans
le minimum légal auxile entre 50 et 75 %
selon les cas et dans les fites
généralement compris entre 60 et 80
%. le sort réservé au dispositif
ultramarin ne doit donc pas être perçu
comme un traitement de faveur il soutend
des équipes des équilibres fragiles qui
n'est pas question de déstabiliser sans
avoir pensé toutes les conséquences de
réformes que l'on voudrait engager cela
ne veut pas dire que le dispositifs sont
immuables mais cela ne veut pas dire non
plus qu'il faut les supprimer dans
l'attente de la révision prochaine de ce
dispositif par le gouvernement comme
monsieur le ministre l'a annoncé il
convient de les maintenir aussi nous
demandons donc que ces deux amendements
ne soient pas
suivis bien monsieur Collin je crois
vous souhaitez oui monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues cher George patient notre
groupe et moi-même sommes tout à fait
convaincus et nous connaissons bien les
difficultés que sont celles du monde
ultramarin et par cet amendement nous
souhaitons pas ajouter euh une
difficulté aux difficultés que vous que
vous connaissez mais effectivement nous
avons été très sensibles à cet avis de
la Cour des comptes il était normal que
nous réagissions et je note avec
satisfaction monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le ministre que la
réflexion qui s'engage va pour
certainement trouver un dispositif euh
qui qui permettent que l'argent public
investi dans des opérations de ce type
en direction du monde ultramaré et dans
leur intérêt d'ailleurs et bien soit
beaucoup mieux utilisé
toute tout euro engagé pour d'argent
public doit allêtre à sa bonne place et
produire le maximum d'effets voilà c'est
notre souci et bien entendu monsieur le
ministre nous suivrons avec beaucoup
d'attention cette réflexion à laquelle
nous associerons si vous le souhaitez
bien entendu et je retire mon amendement
dans cette attente
bien
alors l'amendement 83 est
repris a-il des explications de y a-t-il
des explications de vote monsieur le
Président marign Monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
l'initiative d'Ivan Collin et de son
groupe est utile puisqu'elle nous permet
de de débattre d'un sujet
important je ne suis pas certain que cet
amendement soit appelé à vivre longtemps
mais je l'ai prolongé de quelques
instants car je voulais m'exprimer à son
sujet monsieur le ministre tout à
l'heure vous me faisiez remarquer qu'il
faut avoir de la mémoire dans les débats
budgétaires vous avez une excellente
mémoire
mais vous partagez cette excellente
mémoire avec un certain nombre d'entre
vous et avec un certain nombre d'entre
nous pardon et euh pour ma part j'ai le
souvenir assez précis
d'intervention chaque année sur le thème
de ces contribua privilégiés qui
optimisent leur situation grâce à la
possibilité de déduire de leur impôt sur
le revenu les investissements outreem et
ces attitudes ou ces postures remonte au
demeurant à celui qui avait eu la
première idée de tel positif
c'est-à-dire à l'époque le ministre
Bernard ponce et que n'ai-je entendu
n'est-ce pas de la part des collègues de
l'autre côté de l'hémicycle sur le côté
immoral de tels avantages alors je vois
je vois
qu'aujourd'hui oui mais il s'agissait du
même sujet et les mêmes ne disaient pas
la même chose
et je j'observe simple monsieur le
ministre que dans la loi de finances
pour 2013 vous
déplafonnez les investissement outremè
en terme de de de de calcul de
l'avantage maximal qu'un contribuable à
l'impôt sur le revenu
peut tirer des outils d'investissement
dans lesquels il souscrit je comprends
les arguments économiques que vous avez
évoqué il est bien vrai que la conj
joncture outreem est particulièrement
difficile et que la déstabiliser en
mettant fin euh
à à des mécanismes
euh qui sont assez puissants pour
drainer lesépgne vers les outres m je
comprends bien que ceci ne puisse se
faire facilement mais je voulais
simplement souligner cette cette
contradiction puisque'au total vous
n'êtes pas mécontent pour soutenir
l'économie des outresemes Français et
d'avoir hérité de ces dispositifs que
vous critiquiez tant à guerre et non
seulement vous en héritez mais vous les
prolongez et
compenu des des
contraintes sévères qui s'appliquent en
en en 2013 et du plafonnement plus
exigeant de la dépense fiscale euh par
rapport au au revenus du contribuable et
les investissements outremè vont se
retrouver encore plus que par le passé
au cœur de la stratégie patrimoniale de
celles et ceux qui craignent de payer
beaucoup d'impôts sur le revenus parce
qu'ils ont des revenus euh précisément
confortables ou très confortables alors
pardonnez-moi d'y voir une légère
contradiction et de l'avoir souligné le
temps de faire survivre un peu la
amendement d'ivon CIN et de vous
annoncer monsieur le Président que bien
entendu je le retire bien monsieur le
ministre souhaite néanmoins intervenir
par que le débat est bien sûr
intéressant on connaît les inconvénients
de la défiscalisation nombreux rapports
ont été fait on on connait aussi les
avantages l'économie ultramarine ne se
serait pas développé comme elle s'est
développé sans ses investissements la
question étant de savoir si la dépense
pour l'État est adaptée au résultat que
nous constatons et nous savons que la
dépense est
considérable un chiffre je crois
l'illustre il il n'y a pas je crois
d'investissant d'investissement
permettant d'une année sur l'autre un
rendement aussi élevé et garanti par
l'État ainsi dans le logement social à
la suite d'une disposition que la
précdente majorité avait adopté à la
demande du gouvernement de François
Fillon dans le logement social
l'investissement garanti un rendement de
20 à 25 % d'une année sur l'autre et
garanti sur l'état il n'y a pas
d'investissement plus productif et plus
certain que celui-là est-ce que la
construction de logement social
outremère atteint des niveaux
satisfaisants à chacun de répondre il me
semble qu'avec un tel coût et surtout un
tel rendement pour les investisseurs on
serait peut-être en droit d'espérer
mieux en tout cas la réforme si elle
doit intervenir garantira au moins cet
étatl et ces résultats là et
certainement pas moins je voudrais que
les parlementaires d'outrem on ait
l'absolue conviction deuxième remarque
Pour faire suite à votre propos monsieur
le Président il n'est pas exact que le
gouvernement déplafonne les avantages
fiscaux liés au financement de
l'économie ultramarine le gouvernement
et d'ailleurs je comprends que vous nous
en fassiez reproche le gouvernement
maintient les avantages que vous aviez
vous-même élaborés nous ne les réduisons
ni ne les majorons et ces avantages vous
les connaissez il sont 18000 € plus 4 %
du runi fiscal de référence ce critère
vous le savez à sui quelques évolutions
au cours de ces dernières années mais le
dernier état du droit est celui-là et le
gouvernement ne déplafone donc pas les
avantage l au financement de l'économie
ultramarine monsieur le Président il en
maintient rigoureusement les terres du
droit fiscal tel que la majorité
précédente c'est dire vous-même les avez
les aviez élaboré on peut nous en faire
reproche mais en tout cas on peut pas
nous reprocher d'être contradictoire en
déplafonnant et certainement pas
d'ouvrir les vannes puisque nous
maintenons un dispositif qui semble-t-il
vous satisfaisit merci monsieur le
Président je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre donc l'amendement 83 est retiré
pour la bonne règle je présume que
l'article 84 est retiré n'est pas repris
bien il est donc retiré et nous passons
à après l'article 16 à l'amendement 143
présenté par Monsieur boet bien monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues pour expliquer cet
amendement je souhaite tout d'abord
mettre en avant une argumentation
purement juridique justifiant pleinement
la non déductibilité de la taxe de
risque systémique en droit fiscal les
entreprises peuvent en effet déduire les
dépenses effectuées en vue de
l'acquisition et de la conservation du
revenu comme le précise l'article 13 du
code général des impôts mais la taxe de
risque systémique n'entre pas dans cette
catégorie car elle a été créée à des
fins de stabilisation de la sphère
financière en venant inciter les
établissements à limiter leur prise de
risque cette taxe est donc assise non
sur la production mais sur les risque ne
serait-ce qu'à titre ne serait-ce qu'à
ce titre pardon il convient de la rendre
non déductible sinon son effet incitatif
serait nul puisqu'elle serait
neutralisée or il faut précisément
maximaliser cet effet incitatif je
j'ajoute que d'après le facicule
évaluation des voies et moyens annexé au
projet de loi de finance pour 2013 cette
charge s'élève à environ 260 millions
d'euros même si le taux de la taxe a été
doublé par le collectif budgétaire de
cet été vous comprendrez aisément qu'il
serait finalement assez dommageable que
ce doublement aille de paire avec une
déductibilité is qui mécaniquement a
doublé elle aussi si on maintient son
caractère non déductible on se retrouve
donc avec un crédit d'impôt sur les
sociétés de 83 millions d'euros le tiers
du montant de la taxe pour les
établissements qui sont assujettis ce
n'est pas là me semble-t-il demander un
gros effort aux établissements de crédit
eu égard au nombre des opérations qu'il
réalise tous les jours c'est donc au
bénéfice de ces observations que nous
vous invitons à adopter cet
amendement bien je vous remercie chers
collègues quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à rendre non déductible
à l'impôt sur les sociétés la taxe de
risque systémique introduite par la loi
de finance pour 2011 et dont le taux a
été doublé rappelez-vous par la loi de
finance rectificative de juillet dernier
alors je sais je peux vous dire que
cette taxe systémique elle vise à
limiter le risque et la prise de risque
par les évissements de crédit et que dès
lors il peut paraître tout à fait
logique de la rendre non déductible afin
de maximiser son effet
incitatif j'ajoute que le coût pour les
banques apparaît raisonnable puisqu'il
s'élèverait environ 190 millions d'euros
et dans ces conditions je suis au nom de
la commission des finances tout à fait
favorable à cet amendement qui a été
voté par le Sénat en pour en PLF pour
2012 et qui effectivement dans le
contexte perturbé du monde bancaire et
financer dans lequel nous avons vécu ces
derniers mois ces dernierses années
paraît tout à fait légitime pour essayer
de limiter ce risque
donc favorable à l'amendement de
Monsieur B je vous remercie quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
alors cet amendement qui a été adopté à
lourdirit la charge incontestablement
pour ce secteur il ne s'agit pas comment
dirais-je d'attirer je ne sais quelle
complainte le concernant on sait quelle
fut de manière générale à défaut dans
France sa responsabilité dans la crise
que nous connaissons comme on connaît sa
prospérité mais enfin depuis quelques
temps sa contb la contribution sur le
risque systémique a été doublée la taxe
sur les transactions financière a été
doublée et la nouvelle
tranche de la taxe sur les salaires
concerne vous le savez monsieur le le
sénateur principalement ce secteur parce
que la tranche en
l'espèce le niveau de rémunération
concerné ne se trouve évidemment pas
dans les hôpitaux mais bien dans le
secteur financier vous savez que ces
deux secteurs notamment ne sont pas
soumis à v et donc paye la taxe sur les
salaires cela fait donc en quelques mois
depuis le la loi de finance
rectificative de cet été soit deux taxes
qui ont été doublées soit une taxe qui a
bénéficié qui va bénéficier si le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale est adopté d'une nouvelle
tranche qui vise directement le secteur
financier dans ces conditions je ne
crois pas raisonnable moi je vous le dis
très sincèrement mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je ne crois pas raisonnable de
charger la barque davantage encore
raison pour laquelle le gouvernement
préférerait ne pas voir le Sénat adopter
cette nouvelle taxe même si je comprends
très bien les raisons qui animent et
l'auteur de l'amendement et le
rapporteur général en demandant au
secteur financier de contribuer
davantage encore à l'équilibre de nos
finances publiques je le répète il me
semble que depuis le mois de juillet
nous n'avons pas été timide dans les
efforts demandés à ce secteur et
peut-être faudrait-il cette année du
moins déécritter une forme de pause
quitte à reprendre euh l'année prochaine
cette voilà et pourquoi pas à votre
initiative monsieur le
sénateur je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je vais donc
passer souhaitez intervenir monsieur
président président en un mot pour dire
à Monsieur le Ministre que je ne suis
pas ingrat et que malgré la présentation
qu'il fait des plafonds et que j'ai
trouvé euh à habile mais mais mais mais
quand même un peu un peu spécieuse
n'est-ce pas je vais le soutenir
sur s'agissant de l'amendement qui vient
d'être
présenté parce que je
pense qu'en la
matière surtaxer les transactions sur
action et vous savez que seul les
transactions sur action en France sont
l'objet de la taxe sur les transactions
financières
ce serait une mauvaise chose et
d'ailleurs profondément en opposition
avec l'analyse et les préconisations euh
du rapport Gallois auquel maintenant il
faut se référer comme à la loi et au
Prophète cela va de soi donc monsieur le
ministre j'espère que le rapporteur
général ne m'en voudra pas je je je
soutiendrai le gouvernement contre la
majorité de la commission et ne voterait
pas l'amendement du groupe CRC et quant
au plafond outreemire il est quand même
à 18000 n'est-ce pas alors que tout
alors que le plafond général il est à
baissé à 10000 € ce qui fait qu'il y a
un surplafond outremère de 8000 € ce que
nous n'aurions pas imaginé un instant de
faire enfin je referme la parenthèse
bien monsieur le rapporteur général
oui je je voulais préciser à à mon
collègue président Philippe Marini que
il s'agit bien ici de la trs et non pas
de la TTF vous parlez dans votre
argumentation de la taxe sur les
transactions financières qui peut
appeler des commentaires tels que ce que
vous faites mais il s'agit bien ici de
la taxe de risque systémique et comme le
risque systémique a été dénoncé de
toutes part comme un élément permissif
dans le contexte de crise que nous avons
vécu il apparu à la commission des
finances qu'il était sans doute opportun
de donner des signaux et en l'occurrence
ici en adoptant cet amendement c'est un
signal que nous donnerions ce sens et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
soutenons je retire cette partie de
bien donc je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 143 pour lequel la commission
a donné un avis favorable mais le
gouvernement a donné un avis défavorable
je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre
donc il est adopté il est
adopté nous passons après l'article 16 à
trois amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion
commune le premier le 293 est présenté
par Madame
André merci monsieur le Président notre
collègue sueur aurait aimé défendre cet
amendement je vais vous en donner
l'objet il s'agirait de rendre permanent
le crédit d'impôt pour les métiers d'art
qui doivent être soutenu de manière
pérenne et d'en préciser les conditions
de mise en œuvre ce crédit d'impôt
permet en effet de soutenir des
entreprises dans leur extrême majorité
des PME qui jouent un rôle essentiel
dans la préservation du patrimoine
architectural et culturel de notre pays
avec les retombées induites en matière
d'activité touristique il est par
conséquent nécessaire de permettre à ces
entreprises de poursuivre leur
développement et leur rayonnement sur le
monde à travers la pérénisation de ce
dispositif en outre le fait de
circonscrire les aides à la conception
de nouveaux produits entraîne une
réduction d'assiette du crédit d'impôt
seul salarié en charge du travail
intellectuel préalable à la fabrication
des produits et aux seules entreprises
réalisant des produits innovants or les
avancées dans son secteur sont davantage
d'ordre technique que technologique la
prise en compte des activités d'étude
réalisation permet de ne pas
circonscrire à une dimension purement
intellectuelle le crédit d'impôt métier
d'art qui paraissance et censé
bénéficier à des entreprises de petite
ou moyenne taille non doté d'un bureau
d'étude c'est donc le sens de
l'amendement de Jean-Pierre Sueur pour
le cas
où il ne saurait être pris en compte
positivement je vous demanderai si je
peux reprendre le l'amendement de notre
collègue amoudri 279 qui demandait de le
proroger de de années ce qui a été le
cas régulièrement nous avons d'une année
à l'autre redonné de l'espace pour ce
secteur des métiers d'art et je crois
parce que je l'ai défendu il y a
quelques années sur tous les bans de
cette assemblée je vous remercie donc
Madame André vous ne reprenez pas mais
vous modifiez d'accord le vous rectifiez
donc l'article 200 l'amendement devient
le 293 rectifié bis et d'ailleurs les
deux autres amendements ne sont pas
défendus d'accord
donc donc je vais demander à monsieur le
rapporteur général son avis sur cet
amendement 293 rectifié bis alors il y
avait trois amendements et il semble
qu'il n'en reste plus qu'un qui a pour
objet donc de proposer au-delà du 31
décembre 2012 le crédit d'impôt égal à
10 % des sommes dépensées pour la
conception de nouveaux produits pour les
entreprises exerçant des métiers d'art
alors l'un proposé de projet d'un an
l'autre de deux et puis l'amendement que
Madame André a
défendu proroger sans limitation de date
alors la commission des finances était
favorable au principe de la prorogation
de ce crédit d'impôt qui bénéficie à 800
entreprises artisanal et industriel du
secteur de l'horlogerie la bijouterie la
joie joyerie de l'orfèvrerie de la
lunetterie des arts de la table du jouet
de la facture instrumentale et de
l'ameublement et des Entreprise du
Patrimoine Vivant bref le cœur vivant de
notre patrimoine et de notre
redressement
productif alors ça coûte quand même 24
millions d'euros faut le savoir et euh
si nous y étions favorables et je vous
suggère de lettrre il nous restera à
fixer une nouvelle
échéance une nouvelle date d'échéance à
ce dispositif et donc comme l'amendement
corrigé de Michel André propose de
années c'est donc la suggestion sur
laquelle la commission des finances
pourrait aussi s'accorder puisque
c'était un peu l'idée qu'elle avait
retenu au départ donc c'est un avis
favorable à l'amendement rectifié de
Michel
André monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président bon le
problème est connu beaucoup de candidats
d'ailleurs s'étaient prononcés sur ce
sujet et la question est peut-être une
question de financement mais c'est aussi
une question de fonctionnement de ce
crédit d'impôt qui aujourd'hui n'est pas
efficace dans des dans des circonstances
satisfaisante puisque en fait il
présente un très haut degré d'insécurité
juridique pour ceuxa même qui en
bénéfici avec des contentieux qui sont
malheureusement très nombreux il me
semble que il y a dès lors deux
solutions soit le Sénat adopte ce
dispositif qui devra être précisé car
tel qu'il est rédigé l'amendement je le
crains ne règle pas la question de
l'insécurité juridique soit euh le Sénat
fait confiance au gouvernement qui
souhaite voir manifester cette confiance
en prenant l'engagement qu'une solution
juridiquement satisfaisante sera trouvée
pour le projet de lo finance rtificatif
c'estàd d'ici quelques semaines en
liaison avec vous madame la sénatrice si
vous le souhaitez c'est à votre
convenance si j'ose dire donc moi je
m'en remets à la sagesse du Sénat mais
je souhaite indiquer que le Gouvernement
partage votre préoccupation le
dispositif actuel n'est pas satisfaisant
mais votre amendement je le crains ne
règle pas la situation de manière
satisfaisante en ne faisant pas
totalement litière de l'insécurité
juridique qui existe déjà et qui je le
pense prévaudrait encore avec votre
amendement l'autre alternative c'est de
travailler ensemble pour un amendement
que vous pourriez porter en loit finance
rectificative et qui alors je l'espère
aurait toutes les garanties juridiques
permettant de stabiliser enfin ce régime
auquel je le dis très clairement le
Gouvernement est
favorable madame Andr madame André oui
monsieur le ministre j'entends votre
argumentaire la loi de finance
rectificative est imminente donc je sais
que votre attachement à trouver une
solution pérenne vient d'être
affirmé je je pense que Jean-Pierre ne
nous en voudra pas si ce soir nous nous
disons que nous travaillons pour les
quelques semaines qui viennent dans cet
objectif et je vais donc le retirer
aujourd'hui bien Mons Gillard ne
souhaite plus intervenir bon
d'accordillard avant avant le retrait
non non non il là oui monsieur monsieur
gaillard monsieur avant le retrait
comment on le reprend oui oui moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec cet
amendement donc je le reprend il le
reprend donc monsieur Gaillard vous
venez de reprendre l'amendement rectifié
et qui devient terre et qui devient
terre madame procassia pour expliation
Madame procacia pour explication de vote
oui je veux dire que ce dossier sur les
artisans et les métiers d' c'est un
dossier qui a été défendu au Sénat par
l'ensemble des sénateurs derrière notre
ancienne collègue Catherine Duma et que
j'apprécie que Madame André les présenté
nous nous sommes tous derrière les
artisans et les métiers d'art
et je pense qu'il vaut mieux essayer de
le voter maintenant plutôt que
d'attendre un projet de loi de finance
rectificative ù sait-on jamais on pourra
nous sortir d'autres arguments donc le
groupe um votera cet
amendement bien monsieur le rapporteur
général alors j'ai donné la position de
la Commission des finances sur la
l'amendement tel qu'il était formulé
euh il vient d'être repris par Madame
procasscia euh mais entre temps on a eu
l'explication du ministre et qu'est-ce
qu'il nous a dit le ministre il nous a
dit deux choses il nous a dit tout
d'abord que il avait conscience que le
dispositif actuel n'était en vigueur que
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2012 et que en tout
état de cause il s'engageait à ce que
quelque chose soit fait pour que dès le
1emier janvier 2013 on est un dispositif
de substitution qui corresponde bien à
la réponse qu'il faut apporter pour les
métiers d'art et il nous a dit une
deuxième chose et il s'est engagé à ce
sujet c'est que le projet de loi de
finance rectificative qui va nous être
soumis sous quinzaines va donner lieu à
présentation d'un amendement qui sera
juridiquement sécurisé donc soit on vote
aujourd'hui un dispositif dont la
sécurité juridique n'est pas avérée et
qui pourrait poser problème de ce fait
ou soit on convient d'une coconstruction
d'un dispositif
efficace sécurisé et qui de toute façon
est appelé à être opérationnel au 1er
janvier 2013 voilà dans ces conditions
je crois qu'il vaut mieux s'en tenir à
ce qui nous est suggéré par le ministre
construire quelque chose de solide et
dès lors ne pas s'engager
aujourd'hui dès lors je crois qu' il
faut pas adopter cet amend aujourd'hui
parce que l'engagement prix est très
clair et je pense qu'on peut tout à fait
faire confiance à notre ministre du
Budget sur ce
point bien
donc je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 293 rectifié terire qui est
un
amendementur repris par Monsieur
gaillard pour remettre à César ce qui
est à César
et donc monsieur le ministre
préalablement je vais vous demander si
vous levez le
gage le gage élevé bon bien donc je mets
au
voix pardon dans l'ypothèse adopté voilà
mais je je dois vous le demander je
dans dans l'hypothèse où l'amendement
serait voté c'est dans l'hypothèse où le
Sénat suivant l'opposition um décidait
de ne pas faire confiance au propos que
j'ai pu tenir chose que je ne peux
imaginer dans sa majorité mais dans
l'hypothèse où le Sénat dans sa majorité
ne ferait pas confiance à la demande de
l'opposition UMP dont je m'étonne
d'ailleurs de cette absence de confiance
alors que les engagements sont formels
mais dans l'hypothèse donc où cette
confiance serait mesuré chichement
gouvernement par la majorité de gauche
du Sénat alors je me trouveraai
contraint de lever le gage en regrettant
que la méthode que je crois préférable
et qu'en définitive et Madame André
rapporteur général ont choisi de faire
prévooloir que cette méthode de travail
en commun est bien aboutie enrant donc
que cette méthode ne soit pas privilégié
par le Sénat ce que je ne peux pas
imaginer je monsieur le ministre mais il
m' il m'appartenait sur le plan de la
procédure de vous le demander
préalablement bien madame André
monsieur le Président je ne veux pas
faire durer le débat mais c'est vrai que
dans les années écoulées nous l'avions
prolongé d'une année donc c'était une
mesure de sécurité qui finalement a tenu
jusque-là mais euh et je nous l'avions
voté je me souviens Catherine procacial
ayant présenté comme nous si nos
collègues qui avaient présenté la la
poursuite pour une année ou deux années
étaient là pour expliquer peut-être on
aurait pu avancer un peu mieux mais moi
j'ai conscience complètement du fait que
l'amendement de Jean-Pierre su que nous
avons que nous avons pris à notre compte
nous le groupe socialiste euh présente
des des une vraie difficulté juridique
et donc je pense que c'est de ce fait
curieusement nous ne voterons pas cet
amendement repris qui est le correctif
mais je crois que c'est plus simple et
moi en tout cas je veux dire ici la
confiance que nous accordons que nous
nous accordons tous mutuellement pour
que dans le projet de loi rectificative
nous voyons cette affaire un peu réglé
d'une manière plus pérenne voilà merci
monsieur
Collin oui simplement contte tenu des
arguments donnés par Monsieur le
Ministre comp tenu de la
proximité d'une décision puisque'il ne
s'agit pas d'attendre si
longtemps nous partageons pourtant le
souci effectivement de de cet
amendement et avec le souci bien sûr de
le sécuriser c'est la raison pour
laquelle le notre groupe ne votera pas
cet amendement donc s' n plus l'autre
explication de vote je peux mettre au
voix le 293 rectifié terre qui est pour
il est quoi terre maintenant
d'ailleurs 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté j'ai tout oui c'est
bon plus
bien à l'article 17 je suis saisi de
deux amendements
identiques de
suppression le
premier pas souten il n'est pas soutenu
donc le second est défendu par c'est le
210 il estendu il est défendu par l'UMP
par
l'UMP madame des
ég euh je vais le défendre avec plaisir
monsieur le Président il s'agit dans cet
amendement de supprimer l'article 17
tout simplement qui prévoit une
augmentation de 7 % de la taxe
exceptionnelle instauré par la loi de
finan 2011 sur les réserves de
capitalisation des entreprises
d'assurance bah évidemment cette mesure
elle aurait pour effet corrélatif une
augmentation substantielle des
cotisations d'assurance pour les Assur
parce que c'est sont les assurés qui
vont porter directement le coût de cette
mesure qui devrait rapporter 800
millions d'euros de recettes en 2013
alors l'année dernière je crois qu'il y
avait eu
uneanticipation des mesures par les par
les compagnies mais là il y en aura pas
donc les Français qui vont déjà voir
leurs impôts vont subir encore une
augmentation de leur prime d'assurance
tout ça va diminuer le pouvoir d'achat
c'est la raison pour laquelle cet
amendement vise donc à li la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat des Français je vous
remercie chers collègues quel est votre
avis monsieur le rapporteur général pour
la
Commission le présent article du projet
de loi de de finances a pour objet
d'instaurer une taxe de sortie
complémentaire à celle votée en loi de
finance initiale pour 2011 au taux de 7
% sur la réserve de
capitalisation existante des entreprises
d'assurance mutuelle et institut de
prévoyance alors on peut rappeler que la
loi de finance pour 2011 a mis fin au
régime de faveur dont bénéficier les
dotations sur la réserve de
capitalisation en tant qu'élément des
fonds propres non taxé et cet amendement
vise à supprimer cet article alors bien
entendu je suis défavorable car cette
suppression d'une mesure dont le
rendement est estimé à 800 millions
d'euros serait de nature à fausser
durement l'équilibre de ce projetat de
finance et bien entendu je ne peux que
conseiller au Sénat d'émettre un avis
défavorable monsieur le
ministre même
avis donc je mets au voix madame
procassar madame procassar souhaite
intervenir pour explication de vote oui
très rapidement mettre en cause
l'équilibre du projet de loi de finance
c'est votre objectif mais l'équilibre
des compagnies d'assurance faut
peut-être aussi y songer vous savez très
bien que toutes les nouvelles normes de
solvabilité porte et énormément sur les
compagnies et qu'un bon nombre d'entre
elles les Mutu ne savent pas comment
elles vont pouvoir répondre à Solva et
là en plus on rajoute encore des
taxations moi je m'inquiète sur l'avenir
des compagnies d'assurance n'oubliez pas
que ce sont elles aussi qui financent
l'économie je vous remercie je mets par
conséquent pourit l'amendement
210 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté
je mets au voix maintenant l'article 17
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 17 est adopté même vote pour
le 18 même
vote après l'article
18 je suis saisi d'un amendement numéro
404 mtenant du groupe socialiste et
apparenté madame linman oui monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
monsieur le ministre chers collègues il
s'agit d'aménager la rédaction de
l'article 207 du code général des impôts
qui exonère de l'impôt sur les sociétés
les les organismes HLM et d'ailleurs les
les organismes de d'intérêt général
concernant les loyers perçus au titre de
ces logements mais également des
produits accessoires perçus dans le
cadre de la construction et
l'amélioration de ses logements là il
s'agit d'ajouter à la liste non
seulement les produits de la vente de
des crédits d'économie d'énergie qui
nous paraissent être tout à fait euh
devoir être sorti de ce calcul
puisqu'ils sont nécessaires pour la
rénovation du parc mais mais de manière
plus générale d'autres produits dont les
organismes HLM peuvent bénéficier à
l'occasion de leurs opérations relatives
au logement social par exemple quand il
s'agit de la session par un organisme
HLM de droit lié à un changement d'usage
de locaux prévu par l'article l 6317 du
Code de la Construction donc chers
collègues je pense que cette disposition
serait de nature à améliorer les
finances des organismes et de soutenir
leur effort de réhabilitation en
particuli en particulier
thermique je vous remercie chers
collègues quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le Président cet
amendement vise à exonérer d's les
produits accessoires perçus par les or
HLM et notamment les produits de des
certificats d'économie d'énergie euh je
suis un peu partagé sur cet amendement
et la Commission des finance a partagé
aussi ce point de vue euh en effet il
revient sur l'équilibre actuel du régime
fiscal des bailleurs sociaux qui
distinguent d'une part leurs activités
sociales liées à la production et à
l'amélioration des logements qui sont
exonérés et d'autre part leurs activités
dans le champ concurrentiel qui sont
elles soumises à l'impôt sur les
sociétés dans ces conditions et vu le le
questionnement que ça nous a produit à
la commission des finances il nous a
semblé opportun de recueillir l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre donc quel est l'avis du
ministre merci monsieur le Président
l'exonération d's des bailleurs sociaux
sociaux pardon a déjà un coût pour les
finances publiques qui est de 1
milliards d'euros chaque année certains
peuvent considérer que cette somme est
insuffisante mais personne ne pourra
qu'elle est évidemment conséquente elle
a été étendue pour les produits de
session de certificat d'économie
d'énergie on a eu ce débat madame la
signatrice linman je crois que c'était
samedi donc vous voulez alors aller
encore plus loin en exonérant d'autres
produits je crois qu'en toute chose il
faut savoir rester mesuré donc le
gouvernement n'est pas favorable
l'effort est déjà conséquent sachons
évaluer déjà ce que cet
effort permet en facilité supplémentaire
pour le mouvementm il sera tant le cas
ant de majorer l'effort de l'État mais
tentons déjà d'évaluer celui-là qui est
tout sauf négligeable donc avis
défavorable monsieur le Président
bien bien je vais s'il n'y a pas sil une
explication de vote de Madame
linman la réponse du gouvernement mérite
d'être entendue et celle de Monsieur
Marc aussi à partir du moment où le
gouvernement rappelle son accord qui a
été d'ailleurs donné à l'Assemblée
concernant les certificats d'écon
économie d'énergie qui est quand même le
gros du paquet de cet amendement il me
paraît opportun de pouvoir le de le
retirer toutefois je voudrais attirer
l'attention des collègues sur le fait
qu'il leur arrive souvent dans leur
collectivité d'avoir la nécessité par
exemple de transformer dans une zone en
rue un certain nombre de locaux de bas
d'immeuble pour pouvoir y mettre des
services ou pour pouvoir y mettre des
activités commerciales et que de ce
point de vue il me paraît pas forcément
tout à fait légitime qu'on taxe euh les
le mouvement HLM qui lui-même a des
ressources très limitées mais néanmoins
taxé sur ce principe euh et puis plus
fondamentalement euh je rappelle que le
mouvement les mouvements HLM sont un
service d'intérêt général qu'on leur
fait pas des cadeaux on est en train de
légitimer le fait qu'ils ont des
contraintes ces contraintes c'est un
niveau de loyer qui est calculé sur euh
le niveau des aides publiques et de des
prêts de la Caisse des dépôts et donc il
ne s'agit pas pour ces organismes se
remplir de profit et de dividendes mais
de pouvoir caler les opérations à un
coût de loyer moindre pour nos
concitoyens néanmoins je retire bien sûr
mon amendement et me félicite de
l'effort que le gouvernement a fait pour
le certificat d'énergie l'amendement 404
est retiré j'en viens maintenant après
l'article 18 à l'amendement 67 présenté
par le président Marini merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre c'est
un point assez
technique que je voudrais soulever ici
et je le fais sous forme d'amendement
parce que la direction de la législation
fiscale interrogée il y a quelques mois
n'a pas été en mesure de me
répondre je me réfère à une disposition
issue de la dernière loi de finances
rectificative pour
2010 dans
laquelle vous vous en souvenez
certainement monsieur le ministre avait
été proposée une ambitieuse réforme de
la fiscalité des de la fiscalité des
sociétés de
personnes devant les
effets difficiles à apprécier d'une
réforme aussi complexe le Parlement
avait demandé en lieu et place des
dispositions initialement envisager et
vous vous en souvenez très certainement
un rapport préparatoire à la réforme et
ici au Sénat nous avions considéré que
nous n'étions pas en mesure de rendre un
véritable
avis sur le sujet compte tenu des délais
très faibles qui chaque année sépare euh
la la
transmission de la loi de finances
rectificative de fin d'année examiné par
l'Assemblée nationale au Sénat et en
particulier à la commission des finances
lapse de temps trop faible en l'espèce
pour se faire une opinion euh complète
le texte définitif avait toutefois
modifié l'article 155 du code général
des impôts afin de supprimer la théorie
du bilan fiscal
et 2 ans après la réforme aucune
instruction fiscale n'est venue préciser
les conséquences de l'abandon de cette
théorie et de ce fait de nombreux
professionnell seraient me dit-on dans
l'incapacité d'appliquer correctement
les nouvelles dispositions euh elle-même
assez complexe et pas toujours cohérente
je prends un exemple euh lorsqu'un
agriculteur inscrit des biens non
affecté à son activité professionnelle à
l'actif de son bilan en application
d'article 55 il doit déclarer les
revenus issus de ses biens dans la
catégorie des revenus fonciers en
revanche s'il inscrit à son bilan des
parts de société de personnes départ de
groupement fonciers agricole en l'espèce
il doit en application du Grand 2 de
l'article 238 Bisk du Code Général des
Impôts déterminer la côe partart du
résultat de ce g fa selon les règles des
bénéfices agricoles au total dans des
situations économiques semblables deux
exploitants agricoles seront d'un point
de vue fiscal traité différemment et
c'est pourquoi le présent
amendement propose de rétablir une
égalité de
traitement bien quel est l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement qui a un caractère très
technique on se souvient qu'en loi de
finance rectificative 2010 le Parlement
avait demandé le report de l'essentiel
de la réforme dans l'attente d'un
rapport ce rapport a été remis mais le
gouvernement n'a depuis jamais souhaité
présenter à nouveau ses propositions ni
dans les PLF ni dans les PLFR et je
crois que c'est ça qui pose question et
la commission des finances à la suite de
Philippe Marini on s'est interrogé sur
ce point notamment concernant
l'instruction fiscale d'application des
dispositions qui ont été votées en
décembre 2010 et dans ces conditions il
serait bon monsieur le ministre que vous
nous disiez ce qu'il en est sur ce point
et que vous nous indiquiez peut-être
d'une façon claire à quel moment ces
instructions fiscales vont être publié
donc avis du gouvernement monsieur le
ministre quel est votre avis sur la
question merci Monsieur le le président
pour déterminer la côe part de résultats
du GFA revenant à l'associé exploitant
agricole conformément au principe de
transmdité c'estàdire de
semi-transparence des sociétés de
personnes il convient de raisonner en
deux temps d'abord le résultat du GFA
est déterminé selon les règles propres
au BA au Bénéfic agricoes en extournant
en sortant les produits et les charges
provenant des activités civiles comme
par exemple la location d'un immeuble de
rapport ensuite le résultat des
activités civiles précédemment sorties
sera déterminé et imposé chez l'associé
sonelon les règles propres au revenus
fonciers c'est une conséquence directe
de la translucidité des sociétés de
personnes qui revient à faire comme si
leurs résultats étent réalisés
directement par leurs associés
professionnels et donc à appliquer
l'article 155 du code général des impôts
vous connaissez bien en conséquence le
traitement est donc le même que s'il
avait détenu son immeuble en direct dès
lors il n'y a pas lieu je le crois de
modifier les règles actuelles tout cela
serait naturellement précisé sera sera
naturellement précisé dans l'instruction
qui commentera les conséquence de la
suppression de la théorie du bilan et
qui devrait être publiée monsieur le
Président d'ici la la fin de l'année
bénéfice de ces clarifications je
suggérais que vous retiriez votre
amendement d'appel et naturellement
comme président de la commission des
finances vous serez destinataire
prioritaire de cette instruction dès
lors que celle-ci sera
élaborée monsieur le Président marign je
remercie le ministre de cette
explication circonstanciée qui me permet
de retirer l'amendement ayant obtenu la
réponse qui me paraissait utile pour
clarifier la
situation bien donc l'amendement 67 est
retiré nous en venons après l'article 18
à l'amendement
294 qui est présenté par Madame
André merci notre collègue Michel Delbar
tient beaucoup à cet amendement et vous
comprendrez rapidement pourquoi en vertu
de l'article 293a du Code Général des
Impôts la TVA l'importation est perçue
par la DG DDI l'amendement proposé offre
la possibilité aux entre prise d'opté
soit pour une perception mensuelle de
cette taxe par la DG FIP soit pour une
perception à l'arrivée sur le territoire
français par la DG desdi ce transfert
est nécessaire pour rendre plus
compétitive toute la procédure française
d'importation qui impose actuellement
soit un handicap de financement au PME
françaises utilisant les ports français
plutôt que belges ou hollandais soit une
baisse d'activité pour les ports
français lorsque les importateurs sont
conduits à préférer les ports étrangers
son adoption pour une partie des
importations apporte porterait à la fois
une solution de financement très
appréciable pour les PME et une
augmentation d'activité pour les ports
français ce supplément d'activité
pourrait créer des emplois en France
dans la filière portuaire et logistique
le Grand Port Maritime de dunkerk estime
que cette mesure permettrait c'est un
rapport de juillet 2012 la création de
532 emplois pour la seule région du
nordpcalé la modification proposée
c-dessus de l'article 293a du CGI
apporte une réponse à la fois sécurisée
et ouverte en disposant d'abord que les
non assuétis resteront tenus de payer la
TVA à la DG desdi ensuite en laissant
aux entreprises assugjétis la liberté
d'utiliser en option la procédure de la
déclaration prévue à l'article
287 ce transfert de la TVA et de la de
la DDG DDI vers la DG FIP est une mesure
de simplification elle a été préconisée
tant par l'Inspection générale des
finances que par la Cour des comptes
elle est compatible avec la
réglementation TVA de l'Union européenne
et elle est pratiquée avec succès par la
Belgique et et les Pays-Bas de plus la
douane française percevrait ainsi 25 %
sur les droits de douane des
marchandises rapatriées dans nos ports
et aéroports
merci bien monsieur le ministre quel est
votre avis sur cet
amendement
pardon pardon pardon
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
effectivement une réflexion très
intéressante sur le fonctionnement de la
TVA euh parce que le système actuel
consistant à à s'quit de la TVA
l'importation au moment du dédouinement
c'est-à-dire au moment du paiement des
droits de douane présente l'inconvénient
d'obliger les entreprise à mobiliser les
fonds nécessaires au paiement de la TVA
ce décaissement pouvant avoir un poids
non négligeable sur le
trésorerie à contrario l'autoliquidation
permet de lever la contrainte du
décaissement dès lors elle pourrait
contribuer à l'allègement des frais
financiers pesant sur les entreprises
françaises importatrices tout en
renforçant l'attractivité des PS et des
aéroports
français en Europe cette solution est
retenue en Belgique et aux Pays-Bas
notamment mais le recours à
l'autoliquidation comporte parfois des
risques accrus de fraude et s'il y a des
risques de fraude la commission des
finances s'interroge tout de même sur la
pertinence du dispositif mais c'est le
gouvernement généralement qui sait
mesurer les risques de fraude mieux que
nous à la commission donc on on
s'est reporté à la connaissance de
l'avis du ministre sur ce point parce
que il y a des dispositifs techniques
sur ces affaires de douane
d'autoliquidation de risque de fraude
qui échappe un peu à à notre
perspicacité et certainement que le
ministre va nous éclairer sur ce point
voilà Monsieur le Ministre nototre avis
s'il vous plaît merci Monsieur le le
président euh la lutte contre la fraude
est un objectif que nous partageons
naturellement mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs et d'ailleurs des actions
fortes vont être re mise en œuvre et des
des articles relatifs à la lutte contre
la fraude seront présentés en projet de
bois de finance rectificative
c'est-à-dire de manière imminente vous
en connaissez la la teneur puisque le
projet a été présenté en Conseil des
ministres rendre simultané le paiement
et la déduction de la TVA à
l'importation permettra-t-il de lutter
contre la fraude on peut peut-être en
douter parce que le système actuel de
perception de la TVA à l'importation par
la douane est en fait un gage de
sécurisation contrairement à ce que l'on
pourrait croire des recettes de l'État
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
sur les 27 étatsmbr memb lié par la
directive relative à ces sujets sur 27
États-membres 25 ont choisit le système
qui existe en France c'est-à-dire le
système de perception de la TVA à
l'importation par la douane concernant
la question du financement des PME lié à
la TVA la direction générale des douanes
et des droits indirects la DGDDI a déjà
mis en place depuis 2005 des mesures
comptables en particulier à destination
des PME et visant précisément à alléger
les frais financiers inhérant aux
opérations de commerce international
auxquel ces PME pourrai se livrer et
tant mieux SIAL est le cas ces mesures
ont été jugées satisfaisantes et
suffisantes par l'Inspection Générale
des Finances qui avait été missionné
pour expertiser ce type de processus
enfin du point de vue de la
compétitivité des ports français
l'amendement proposé ne n'est pas utile
semble-t-il puisque la comparaison
internationale et notamment l'expérience
de l'Allemagne et de l'Espagne dont les
ports sont particulièrement compétitifs
avec un dispositif similaire à celui de
la France ne semble pas plaider en
faveur d'une réforme que vous semblez
vouloir défendre donc je pense que
l'objectif que nous partageons est le
même il semble que le système actuel
soit satisfaisant je crois pas
indispensable de le modifié si j'en juge
notamment je l'ai indiqué par ce qu'est
la pratique internationale qui conforte
les choix que la France a pu faire une
mission de l'Inspection générale des
finances a également accrédité l'idée
que ce système était efficace pour
sécuriser les recettes de l'État donc je
vous suggérais madame la signatrice au
bénéfice de ces informations qui
n'étaiit peut-être pas suffisamment
connu et et le tort en revient
naturellement au ministère du budget
mais au bénéfice de ces informations
peut-être pourriez-vous maintenant
retirer cet
amendement monsieur auparavant le
président Marini souhaiterait intervenir
oui
ministre je suis assez surpris de vos
de vos arguments
car il est bien vrai que dans notre
système les entreprises qui importent
doivent effectivement décaisser le
montant de la TVA
et si l'on comprend bien parce que la
question si je ne me trompe a déjà été
posée dans des débats budgétaires si
l'on comprend bien que la direction
générale des douanes ce soit de tout
temps opposé à la solution fiscale et
qu'elle cherche donc à préserver son
rôle régalien et il n'en est pas moins
vrai que du point de vue de la
compétitivité le système qui est le
nôtre fait appel à la trésorerie des
entreprises plus que ce ne serait le cas
si l'on suivait la
proposition de notre collègue Michel
Delbard qui me sem semble être bien
placé pour savoir que le Grand Port
Maritime de
dkererque considère qu'il y a un enjeu
de plusieurs centaines d'emplois qui
pourrait être créé si la compétitivité
était améliorée par rapport au au au au
au au port flamand
et j'ai également
entendu des arguments identiques en
matière de frais euh aériens
euh et les les les leçons tirées euh du
rapport de l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui avait été si je ne me
trompe confié à Monsieur rouvilois euh
n'apparaissent pas interprété de la même
manière de part et d'autre donc
euh la réponse très très fermée que vous
avez faite à notre collègue
ne me semble pas épuiser le débat
et peut-être serait-il util monsieur le
ministre que vous acceptiez un groupe de
travail ou un dispositif adéquat qui
permettent de de de mettre sur la table
les arguments avec les parlementaires
concernés par les questions portuaire je
me
permets je me permets d'insister en CE
sens compte tenu de la nécessaire
solidarité qui existe entre les
promoteurs du canal saine Nord Europe
monsieur le
ministre monsieur le
ministre il m'est difficile de m'engager
en lier place de de Frédéric cuviler
donc ce serait naturellement le le rôle
mais en tout cas monsieur le Président
si cela peut vous amener un peu
d'indulgence je parle je parle de la
question des ports cela doit vous amener
un peu d'indulgence à la Gard du
gouvernement je je peux vous assurer que
dès mercredi prochain au Conseil des
ministres je laiss en lui suggérant très
fortement la constitution de ce GR de
travail à supposer qu'il en existe pas
déjà un sur la compétitivité des ports
la chose n'est quand même pas totalement
exclue car ce problème existe depuis
longtemps vous avez par ailleurs soulevé
une question qui est réelle vous avez
indiqué que l'administration des douanes
ne voit pas d'un œil extraordinairement
favorable les modifications actuelles de
la réglementation de la loi c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais ce n'est pas parce
qu'elle ne le voit pas d'un œil
favorable qu'elle a tort de l'envisager
défavorablement je pense que c'est ta
raison qu'elle le fait et j'en veux
encore une fois pour preuve le fait que
les ports allemands ou espagnols sont
très compétitifs ont en réalité le même
dispositif que les ports français en la
matière toute chose n'est pas égale par
ailleurs son pas mais en la matière la
la même chose et il me semble que cette
comparaison internationale faire partie
des 25 sur les 27 pays d'Europe qui
appliquent ce type de dispositif ne
plaide pas contte donc je transmettrai à
Frédéric hvilier votre demande que je
trouve légitime et je maintiens demande
de de retrait d'amendement si vous
voulez bien madame la sénatrice au
bénéfice des explications que je me suis
permis de vous apporter madame
André monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président de la Commission monsieur
Marini je n'ai pas entendu la réponse la
première réponse du ministre comme fermé
elle elle donnait quelques
aperçus sur l'inconvénient avantage des
deux et donc je pense que Michel Delbar
serait sans doute à cette place mieux à
même d'apporter des précisions et de
parler du Grand por
d'unkererque ce qui est moins dans ma
dans ma vision
habituelle de circonscription
continentale volcanique certes mais pas
dans le domaine
portuaire donc je pense qu'il est plus
sage et que les collègues de mon groupe
pensent qu'il est plus sage de retirer
cet amendement mais il est utile sans
doute de retravailler sur la question
puisqu'elle a déjà été posée dans le
passé qu'elle concerne aussi bien les
taxes port aéroport et que certainement
elle doit peut-être pas au Conseil des
ministres mercredi prochain monsieur le
ministre il y a peut-être plus urgents à
faire mais peut-être dans un avenir
proche donc l'amendement 294 est retiré
je vous remercie après l'article 18 j'en
viens à un amendement 200 qui est
présenté par Monsieur de Mongolfier oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre mes chers collègues il s'agit
tout simplement de rétablir deux
dispositions importantes du dispositif
de l'aide médicale d'État qui Ava été
supprimé lors de loi de finance
rectificative pour 2012 il s'agit d'une
part d'instaurer un droit forfaitaire
annuel qui serait porté à 50 € et par
ailleurs de rétablir la procéure
d'agrément préalable pour les soins
hospitaliers les plus coûteux ce sont
deux mesures qui ont pour vocation de
renforcer la bonne disposition du
dispositif d'ame pour des questions à la
fois éthiques et sanitaires merci
je vous remercie chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur général
oui il s'agit monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues de
rétablir d'une part le droit de TH pour
les demandeurs majeurs de l'aide
médicale d'État dont il est proposer de
fixer le montant à 50 € par
an et d'autre part l'agrément préalable
pour les soins hospitaliers coûteux dé
livvré au bénéficiairees du dispositif
c'est 30 € au lieu de 50 50 ou 50 oui
donc don bien entendu je suis
défavorable à à cet amendement car sans
permettre la réisation d'économie il va
imitablement réduire l'accès à l'aide
médicale d'État et ceci
n'est acceptable ni d'un point de vue
humanitaire ni d'un point de vue
sanitaire me semble-t-il et donc je
propose un avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre même avis monsieur le Président
je vous remercie madame procacia puis
madame ensuite oui merci monsieur le
président pendant le projet doit de
finance rectificatif au mois de juillet
nous avions déjà évoqué le problème de
la MA plus que le coût c'est l'appel et
l'inégalité d'accès par rapport à des
immigrés en situation régulière ou à des
Français qui n'ont pas les qui n'ont pas
de moyens et qui eux doivent payer une
petite partie de ces frais et depuis les
débats de cet été je peux vous dire que
l'on a trouvé
dans de nombreux endroits sur des forums
ou ailleurs des Français ou des immigrés
qui sont en situation tout à fait
régulière qui estiment que c'est une
injustice qui leur est faite depuis cet
été et les débats que nous avons eu des
choses ont avancé puisque nous avions
soulevé le problème des médicaments
génériques puisque les bénéficiaires de
l'AME pouvaient refuser les médicament
générique en pharmacie et pas tous les
autres personnes bénéficiant de
l'assurance mal dit je crois savoir que
l'on est revenu sur cette disposition et
je m'en félicite par contre et là je
parle toujours finance et budget euh en
matière d'hôpitaux en matière d'hôpitaux
les hôpitaux peuvent facturer les soins
pour des ame au prix qu'ils veulent
alors que vous moi ou n'importe qui on
va se faire soigner une main ou aller
chez l' Torino euh la tarification est
fixée pour les ame elle est libre et
comme par hasard ce montant est beaucoup
plus élevé je sais je n'ai pas redéposé
cet amendement puisque cet été euh il
avait été repoussé donc inutile de
revenir mais puisqu'on a avancé sur les
génériques et bien et qu'on est sur le
budget de l'État j'aimerais bien que
l'on réfléchisse un peu plus euh sur
cette nouvelle distorsion qui là n'est
pas un problème d'accès aux soins mais
de tarification beaucoup plus élevée des
soins pour des personnes et rien ne
justifie cette tarification plus élevée
je vous remercie madame desego pour
explication
noite merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
moi je voterai cet amendement de de
rétablissement de de la
franchise pour la me proposée par notre
collègue alberériic de bongolfier au nom
du groupe UMP je je le voterai et c'est
vrai que cette suppression en juillet
dernier du droit d'entrée de de 30 € et
de l'autorisation préalable de prise en
en charge pour les soins hospitaliers
c'est quand même mes chers collègues un
de 3 million d'euros en 2012 et comme
vient de le dire Catherine brocaia c'est
profondément injuste sa suppression au
Bénéfic d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière à laquelle il faut ajouter
la diminution de 31 % du montant de la
taxe de primau délivrance de droits
commun des titres aux étrangers tel que
proposé à l'article 29 de ce projet de
loi de finance que nous allons examiner
c'est a cadeaux fiscaux du gouvernement
en faveur des ressortissants étrangers
alors que dans le même temps et ben on
demande des efforts importants au
français en matière d'économie de
dépenses de santé un effort de 10
milliards d'euros d'impôt
supplémentaires à l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes voilà donc c'est pas c'est
pas logique parce que en plus cette
somme de 30 € elle couvre quand même des
frais d'ouverture de dossier la
fabrication de la carte sécurisée et et
ça paraissait
absolument supportable et surtout ça
visait à dissuader les abus en matière
de soins des personnes en situation
irrégulière au regard de nombreux
dysfonctionnements et d'abus constatés
on peut pas le nier avec une ame au
budget en croissance exponentielle donc
vraiment pour toutes ces raisons cet
amendement me paraît pertinent et je le
voterai bien la parole est à Monsieur J
pour explication de
vote
merci monsieur le Président et ben je
vois avec plaisir qu'on avance pas dans
les débats on a déjà eu ce débat au
moment des lois
Besson des lois Hortefeu ça a toujours
été votre
orientation supprimer laame empêcher
laame laame c'est la porte ouverte à
tous les abus c'est ce qui tire tous ces
étrangers qui malad cherchent à rentrer
sur notre territoire pour se faire
soigner gratuitement à nos frais et
cetera et
bien tous les praticiens nous le disent
et vous le disent et vous le savez très
bien si les étrangers en situation
irrégulière ne sont pas soignés dans ce
cadre là de toute façon vous les
retrouverez au service d'urgence des
hôpitaux et vous aurez à les soigner et
ça coûtera encore plus cher et ça
coûtera encore plus cher tous les
spécialistes et tous les praticiens nous
le disent on a déjà eu ce débat 10 fois
donc
franchement au lieu de faire de la
démagogie et du populisme je vous le dis
franchement je pense que le Sénat se
grandirait en rejetant cet amendement
iniique bien
je vais donc mettre au voix cet
amendement ah Monsieur fouco excusez-moi
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
partage le sentiment de notre collègue
youun parce
que le problème c'est que le débat
n'avance pas et l'UMP c'est toujours les
mêmes questions qui qui qui sont posées
c'est s'attaquer tour à tour à l'égalité
du traitement fiscal des revenus du
capital et du travail l'ajustation des
des des plusvalue à remise sur pied de
l'impôt de solidarité sur la fortune et
désormais et désormais nous les trouvons
sur un amendement tendant à faire payer
aux bénéficiaires de l'aide médicale
d'État un droit d'accès aux soins
forfaitaires le problème mes chers
collègues de l'UMP c'est que laame et
précisément je dirais le type de dépense
dont il convient qu'elle fussent qu'elle
fut réalisée pour générer quelques
économies ult érieur autant pour le
budget général que en même temps pour le
budget de la Sécurité sociale
excusez-moi on va prendre un exemple
simple supposons qu'il viennent à passer
en France un de sur notre territoire un
de ces pauvres et que ce malheureux ne
soit porteur de quelques maladie
contagieuse pour le moins inquiétante et
que son affection soit diffusée faute de
soins comment faisait-on alors notamment
au motif qu' n'y aura pas à quitter les
fameux 30 € hein ce que vous demandez de
droit que vous entendez rétablir et bien
nous aurons peut-être là un être humain
en souffrance malade et répandant autour
de lui le mal qui qui le frappe rendant
d'autres personnes malades alors comme
l'a rappelé notre collègue comme il a
été rappelé tout à l'heure par les
collègues au sein de la gauche la bonne
gestion des affaires publi mes chers
collègues ce n'est pas de feindre
résoudre le problème du financement de
l'aide médic
en demandant à ses
bénéficiaires une sorte de forcef la
bonne gestion comme il a été rappelé à
l'instant c'est de soigner et de soigner
au plusutôt avec les moyens disponibles
immédiatement pour éviter éviter
justement que ce qui est d'abord et
avant tout un problème de santé
personnelle ne devienne un problème
collectif c'est pour cela que le groupe
CRC vtera bien sûr contre l'amendement
qui a été présenté par Monsieur de
monolf
bien je n'ai plus d'explication de vote
donc je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement numéro
200 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté après l'article
18 nous avons un amendement 431 rectifié
qui est présenté par Monsieur Marc au
nom de la commission des
finances merci monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues il s'agit de du fameux
amendement CFE qui répond à à une
préoccupation du moment dans beaucoup de
nos collectivités et vous savez que les
règles actuelles qui autorisent les
communes et les EPCI à fixer des bases
de calcul de la CFE la cotisation
minimale entre 200 et 6000 € en fonction
du chiffre d'affaires ont parfois
entraîné des augmentations considérable
de l'impôt dû par certaines petites
entreprises les collectivités
territoriales elles-mêmes se sont
inquiété de ces effets dont elle n'avait
pas nécessairement pu prendre la mesure
faute de simulation suffisante ou
disponible même parfois le présent
amendement tend dès lors à apporter une
première réponse à ces difficultés en
autorisant les collectivités à revenir
exceptionnellement si elle le souhaite
sur leur délibération prise Aué de 2002
12 dans sa version initiale la
commission des Finances avait prévu que
le surplu de cotisation versé par les
contribuables
s'imputerait comme à compte sur la cfe2
pour les exercices 2013 et
2014 mais après discussion avec le
gouvernement et les services il est
apparu possible de prévoir un mécanisme
qui permettrait au contribuables de
n'acquiter que la cotisation résultant
de l'éventuelle nouvelle délibération et
donc à ne pas sortir la trésorerie
supplémentaire c'est bien entendu plus
commode
ainsi l'État versera aux collectivités
début 2013 les accondes mensuels
correspondant au montant de cotisation
minimum de cfeux initiaux mais il
n'opérera de recouvrement auprès des
redevables que sur la base des nouveaux
montants les collectivités rembourseront
à l'état la différence des sommes
perçues au titre de l'ancienne
délibération et de la nouvelle
tel est le mécanisme prévu par la
version rectifiée de l'amendement et dès
lors que l'État nous dit que ces
services sont en en totale capacité
d'opérer sur cette base ce que nous
n'avions pu anticiper nous à la
commission des finances nous sommes bien
entendu tout à fait favorbles à ce que
ce mécanisme financier plus intéressant
bien sûr pour les commerçants les
artisans et les PME soit validé c'est ce
que nous avons donc donc introduit
monsieur le Président dans l'amendement
et j'imagine que ça devrait satisfaire
ceux de nos collègues de la commission
des finances qui n'en avaiit pas eu
connaissance jusque-là mais qui dans
l'esprit je pense seront satisfaits de
voir qu'on apporte une réponse encore
améliorée à la préoccupation qui avit
été exprimé par les commercian artisans
voilà l'objet de cet amendement je
précise que euh nous avons le souhait
aussi la Commission des finance nous en
avion convenu d'aller au-delà dans la
réflexion pour les années à venir parce
qu'on a conscience qu'il faut régler
dans l'urgence un problème qui est posé
euh à l'instanté mais que sur le
mécanisme lui-même de la cotisation
minimale il y a sans doute lieu de
réfléchir notamment quant à l'incidence
de ce seuil de chiffre d'affaires qui
n'est pas toujours le plus pertinent
semble-t-il et on nous suggère ici et là
que la valeur ajoutée soit préférée dans
l'examen des des modalités de fixation
de cette condition minimale donc c'est
le travail des des mois à venir mais
dans l'immédiat il s'agit de s'ent tenir
à cet amendement qui je crois
permettrait de régler la situation telle
qu'elle aujourd'hui pose problème aux
commerçants artisans et aux
PME je vous remercie monsieur le
rapporteur général quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
le Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement car il s'agit de palier les
conséquences je crois très
préjudiciables euh de la réforme de la
taxe professionnelle dont on sait dans
quelles conditions elle fut préparée et
soumise au Parlement j'ai pour ma part
le souvenir assez exact d'un projet
quasiment intégralement réécrit par le
Parlement tant la chose fut mal faite
par le pouvoir exécutif de l'époque
parmi mal prise
oui écrit deux fois pardon tout à fait
oui il a fallu la réécrire deux fois
vous avez parfaitement raison monsieur
le Président donc vous renforcez le
message que je m forcé de faire passer
plus subtilement que vous ne semblit le
souhaiter
bien parmi ces conséquence il y a le
fait que des collectivités locales assez
bien réparties sur les Chiquet
politiques je je dois le reconnaître
devant le Sénat ont très fortement
augmenté la cotisation minimale entre
2011 et
2012 je crois pas qu'il faille le
rentenir exagérément grief la crainte de
manquer de ressources a le plus souvent
présidé à cette très forte augmentation
mais l'augmentation dans certains cas
est tout à fait considérable et
maintenant que ces augmentations se
traduisent
par des rôles reçus par les
contribuables un certain émoi s fait
jour notamment chez les élus locaux
ayant d'ailleurs particulièrement été
actif dans le vote de ces fortes Hauses
de cotisation minimal il faut donc
corriger cela l'amendement présenté par
le rapporteur général je crois il
pourvoit il s'agit bien de permettre en
fait au collectivité de délibérer à
nouveau en attendant j'ai donné des
instructions à la direction générale des
finances publiques pour que les délis de
paiement les plus larges soitent
accordés permettant effectivement aux
collectivités locales qui le
souhaiteraient de revenir sur ces
délibérations et à défaut d'assumer
devant les chefs d'entreprise concerné
ces hausses qui sont imputables non pas
au gouvernement précédent strict au
sessus encore moins au gouvernement
actuel mais bien aux élus locaux ayant
délibéré en ce sens certains n'ayant
probablement pas F pas pu faire
autrement mais il demeure que cette
délibération fut à l'initiative et à la
conclusion le fait des élus locaux donc
avis favorable monsieur le rapporteur
général euh vous souhaitez intervenir
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président pour remercier le rapporteur
général du travail qu'il a accompli
remercier l'ensemble des collègues
membres de la commission des finances
puisque nous avons souscrit à
l'unanimité à cette initiative qui a été
en effet amélioré grâce à une
concertation utile avec le gouvernement
et ses services donc mes chers collègues
je pense qu'à la suite de
l'émoi qui s'est notamment exprimé lors
de l'assemblée générale de l'Association
des maires de France la semaine dernière
et à la suite de l'analyse que nous
avons faite de ce sujet le Sénat est en
mesure d'apporter une
réponse technique
concrète et Monsieur ministre ceci
devrait au moins permettre de de de de
de résoudre l'une des nombreuses
difficultés issues de cette réforme que
vous avez rappelé tout à l'heure bien
monsieur le rapporteur
général une petite précision technique
parce que en langage fiscal cotisation
minimale et cotisation minimum ça ne
veut pas dire la même chose donc pour le
conrendu je j'ai bien voulu parler tout
à l'heure de la cotisation minimum et
non pas la cotisation minimale que j'ai
utilisé par erreur
euh de de de la même façon la question
posée par certains collègues pourquoi le
21 janvier 2013 comme date fatidique
pour délibération c'est aussi une date
qui a une signification particulière
pour les services fiscaux donc voyez
qu'on parle le langage de des services
et je remercie j'en profite aussi comme
le président Marini pour remercier le
ministre de d'avoir donné toutes les les
directives nécessaires pour qu'on puisse
résoudre ce problème donc je remercie
beaucoup le le ministre et ses services
de leur collaboration très utile pour
résoudre ce
problème la parole est à Monsieur dela
pour explication de vote oui monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues quelques mots sur cet
amendement puisque le groupe udu UC a
déposé aussi un amendement sur la CFE
qui qui va suivre que je présenterai
juste après mais c'est vrai que le
ministre nous a rappelé que sur la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle il y
avait une réécrite ure importante du
texte au niveau
législatif c'est vrai on a l'habitude en
France de souvent compliquer les les
réformes et la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle a finalement accouché
d'unun système beaucoup plus compliqué
que ce qui était la réforme ce quiétait
la taxe professionnelle à l'origine et
on a encore eu un exemple récemment avec
l'article 6 que nous n'avons pas voté
ici qui étit réécrit suite à au
mouvement d'ID des pigeon et qui était
d'une complexité absolue donc on est on
est les les rois je crois en terme de de
complexité des textes et et à chaque
fois qu'on annonce que ça va être plus
simple c'est toujours beaucoup plus
compliqué alors moi je me réjouis
effectivement de cette possibilité pour
les entreprises de payer moins ou en
tout cas pour pour les collectivité de
rembourser et qu'ensuite l'état
remboursera euh je pense que l'idée
quand même d'aller un petit peu plus
loin bien sûr dans la la réforme
peut-être et de proposer d'une réforme
plus importante en 2013 mais vous le
verrez avec l'amendement que nous
proposons nous proposons de réduire le
plafond parce que le plafond a été
augmenté sans doute dans des proportions
beaucoup trop importantes certaines
collectivités ne se sont pas rendu
compte de l'impact que ça pouvait avoir
sur leurs entreprises
donc nous not notre souhait ça serait
d'aller un petit peu plus loin et de de
réduire ce plafond et de revenir au
plafond antérieur voilà mais nous
voterons l'amendement de la commission
des finances puisque nous avons
participé à son
élaboration je vous remerci chers
collègue la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur repsamen pour explication de
vot merci monsieur le Président je
voulais joindre ma voix à celle de mes
collègues pour féliciter le rapporteur
général le travail qui éta fait par la
commission des finances et remercier le
le gouvernement de de sa
réponse je dois dire à notre collègue
que la complexité
fiscale telle qu'elle atteint en France
est aussi souvent le signe d'une
démocratie avancée
il faut toujours garder ça en tête c'est
toujours dans les démocraties les plus
évoluées que la complexité fiscale est
la plus grande mais je vis dire au
ministre faire au ministre de deux
remarques la première c'est l'absence
totale de simulation fourni que N pu
fournir justementadministration fiscale
qui a bien souvent
entraîné ces ses difficultés simulation
vous l'avez rappelé qu'elle ne pouvait
pas fournir faute de en raison de la
rapidité et de la complexité des mesures
mais je voudrais également pour plus
tard alerter nos collègues sur le le
mauvais choix qui est fait du seuil de
100000 € de chiffre d'affaires ça a été
évoqué l'autre jour en en commission des
finances 100000 € ça crée un effet de
seuil terrible mais c'est jusqu'à 200000
€ que les commerçants et artisans voire
250000 € que les commçants et les
artisans sont sont très frappés cette
mesure il faut le savoir taxe beaucoup
plus lourdement quand la fiscalité a été
augmenté par les collectivités les
artisans et les commerçants mais elle
procure des avantages
indéiables à certains contribuables je
pourrais donner ici l'exemple que j'ai
donné en commission des finances de
l'agglomération du jeunesse de ma
collectivité nous avions pris un taux
moyen de 4000 € et où certains
contribuables vont gagner jusqu'à 66000
€ et d'autres voir une augmentation de
leur cotisation de 1000 € donc il y aura
il y a bien des gagnants des vrais
gagnants et nombreux petits perdants et
donc c'est pourquoi je souhaite que
l'année prochaine en tous les cas avec
un peu plus de calme et
de retour on puisse modifier ce seuil de
100000 € qui comme tous les seuils posé
un peu arbitrairement entraînne des
problèmes
particuliers merci la parole est à
Monsieur de
monolfier merci Monsieur président
monsieur le ministre le groupe UMP
votera cet amendement remerciant à son
tour le rapporteur général et et le
ministre de ses précisions parce que il
faut quand même rétablir la vérité la
difficulté que nous rencontrons n'est
pas la conséquence directe de la réforme
de la taxe professionnelle c'est plutôt
en effet des décisions des délibérations
de collectivité qui il est vrai n'ont
pas toujours eu les éléments
d'information notamment de la part des
directions départementale des finances
publiques on a beaucoup de mal et c'est
peut-être dû à la déferland de réforme à
avoir les affirmations et en temps et en
heure bon toujours est-il que grâce à
cet amendement on ouvre une possibilité
euh de revenir sur des décisions qui
sont parfois aux conséquences
difficilement mesurables je crois que
c'est une décision de bon sens auquel on
s'associe
volontiers je vous remercie la la parole
est à monsieur Gautier pour explication
de
vote monsie colollin il n
pas oui monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues bien sûr
je me félicite moi aussi de cet
amendement et je le voterai D demain
mais je voudrais rappeler au ministre
qui évoquait que les collectivités
avaient peur de manquer de recettes pour
une intercommunité comme la mienne nous
avons payé au afpic 500000 € en 2012 on
nous avait annoncé 1400000 pour 2013
donc un triplement et finalement nous
allons payer 1900000 € c'est-à-dire 30 %
plus le triplleement c'est vous dire que
les collectivités ont quand même du mal
à prévoir des budgets et qu'elles
doivent trouver les
recettes bien la parole est à Monsieur
Collin pour explication de vote oui
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
rapporteur général a rappeler que faute
de simulation nombreuses collectivités
se sont engagées imprudemment et on
connaît tous les conséquences qui en a
résulté cela a soulevé pas mal
d'émotions la proposition de
l'amendement de notre rapporteur général
que je félicite et remercie à mon tour
de cette proposition
rétablit remet les choses dans le bon
sens je crois que c'est une bonne chose
et le RDSE bien entendu s'associera à
cette à cet amendement votant
favorablement je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur fouco pour
explication de VO merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre moi la
différence de Monsieur de de
montgolphier je dirais que cet
amendement souligne une fois encore les
limites de la réforme de la taxe de la
taxe professionnel soi-disant la grande
réforme du quinquena Sarkozi en matière
de fiscalité locale à savoir la
suppression de C taxes je ne vais pas
rappeler ici quelle était à l'époque la
position de notre groupe mais puisque
s'est tenu le le Congrès des Maires
peut-être de rappeler la la position
enfin si on en en croit d'ailleurs André
Lenel ancien ministre et actuel
président des du Comité des finances
locales la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle a de fait été payé par
les ménages puisque le transfert de
fiscalité n'a pas manqué de se produire
à leur détriment et la facture monsieur
de Montgolfier de 7,5 milliards
d'allègements euh a pris les formes je
dirais autorisées de la taxe
d'habitation du foncier bâti ou encore
plus discrètement de la taxe
d'enlèvement des ordures ménagères
faut-il le rappeler autre phénomène que
l'on avait oublié en route celui de
l'absence de mesure des conséquences
d'un pouvoir local je dirais de plus en
plus limité dans la fixation de l'impôt
la la taxe professionnelle a été
remplacé comme vous le savez par la
contribution économique territoriale que
nous avions qualifié en son temps de
mariage de la carpe et du lapin
associant une sorte de résurgence de
l'antique patente et une majoration de
la taxe sur la valeur ajoutée parce que
voilà quand même ne pouvant plus agir
aujourd'hui que sur la seule cotisation
foncière des entreprises hein faut-il le
rappeler les élus locaux se sont
retrouvés à devoir voter des taux
d'imposition sans sans disposer des
éléments de mesure effectif de leur
choix le ministre l'a rappelé il y a
quelques instants ainsi que le
rapporteur général un peu d'ailleurs
comme si on avait demandé aux élus de
voter quelques chose en gardant les yeux
bandés une sorte de Colin Maillard
fiscal où certaines entreprises étaient
gagnantes notre collègue président du
groupe socialiste monsieur RAM Salem a
raison de de rappeler hein ce sont euh
ce fut le cas pour 80 % d'entre elles et
quelques autres les 20 % restants qui
ont été pour le moins malheureusement
perdante alors cette évaluation de la
réforme de la taxe professionnelle n'a
pas encore été tout à fait réalisée et
pas tout à fait accompli mais si l'on
sait que l'industrie et un grand nombre
de PME et de TI ont vu leur contribution
se réduire il n'en a pas été de même
hein je vais pas m'étendre là-dessus euh
pour un grand nombre alors pour certains
la douloureuse surprise fut de constater
une hausse des cotisations conduisant à
devoir payer 3 qu C fois plus
qu'auparavant au point de mettre en
question la survie d'entreprise déjà
particulièrement sensible à la
stagnation du pouvoir d'achat de leur
clientèle alors on peut effectivement
comprendre leur
colère comme on doit aussi comprendre et
bien comprendre l'embarras en tout cas
la situation des élus locaux qui n'ont
pas envisagé les conséquences de leur
décisions faute faute d'éléments
d'appréciation suffisamment fiable
fourni en en son temps et heure par les
services il est donc écrit dans
l'amendement que faculté va être laissée
au collectivité local de revenir sur
leur délibération en vue de faire des
sommes d'ors et déjà versé des àomtes
pour les années à venir je dirais une
solution de moindre mal si l'on peut
dire que nous voterons par solidarité
avec nos collèges avec des desés armées
devant des situations pour certaines
ubuesque mais qui nous enseignent pour
le moins l'essentiel en attendant même
si cet amendement n'est qu'une sorte de
faute de mieux nous ne pourrons que le
voter avant que de nous donner
rendez-vous je pense j'espère pour une
vraie réforme de la fiscalité locale
peut-être pour l'acte 3 de la
décentralisation par
exemple il n'y a plus d'autres
explication de
vote par conséquent demander à Monsieur
le Ministre s'il lève le gage dans ses
deux
composantes non vous devez le faire
avant monsieur le
ministre parz-moi monsieur le Président
oui bien sûr je le gage puisque le
gouvernement donne un avis favorable je
vis simplement répondre à quelques éus
locaux que il est possible que dans
certains cas les simulations est été
absente suffisamment précise pour autant
quand on quintuple la cotisation minimum
il n'est pas surprenant qu'ensuite ceux
qui sont redevlables de cette cotisation
s'étonne de l'augmentation donc je veux
bien que l'on reproche la direction
général des finances publiques de ne pas
avoir calculé précisément à quoi
aboutissait le quintuplement de la
cotisation minimum mais en même temps
permettez-moi de dire peut-être mon
étonnement devant l'étonnement d'élus
locaux constatant les résultats du
quintuplement d'une cotisation minimum
je lève le
gage je vous remercie monsieur le
ministre je donc vous demander de passer
au voix cet amendement 431 rectifié qui
devient
bis qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est donc
adopté nous en venons après
l'article
18 à l'amendement
352 qui est présenté
monsieur de par Monsieur de
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est cet
amendement je l'ai annoncé tout à
l'heure il est toujours dans le cadre de
la
CFE c'est vrai que les collectivités
locales qui ont augmenté soit leur
cotisation minimum soit qui ont profité
des effets du plafond se doutait bien je
pense quand même même s'il y avait pas
d'évaluation précis que ça allait
entraîner une augmentation de la charge
sur les contribuables ça me paraît assez
évident pour éviter les tentations il
nous a semblé nécessaire de limiter de
revenir au plafond
antérieur qui
était celui avant la loi de finance
rectificative de l'année 2011 et qui
était à 2023 € on est passé de 2023 à
6000 € donc l'objet de cet amendement
c'était de de revenir à ce plafond pour
éviter les tentations de chercher des
recettes peut-être pas hyper
conséquentes par rapport au pic qui a
été évoqué tout à l'heure mais qui sont
quand même des recettes pas négligebles
pour certaines collectivités donc éviter
cette tentation en limitant le plafond
et en revenant à plafond à 2023 alors
dans dans l'amendement nous avions
aussi l'idée que il y aura un
dégrèvement en 2013 pour ceux qui
avaient payé trop en 2012 ça a été réglé
par l'amendement que nous venons
d'adopter précédemment l'amendement du
rapporteur général donc voilà je moi je
pense qu'il serait souhaitable quand
même de de limiter le la hauteur du
plafond pour limiter les tentations des
collectivités
locales je vous remercie chers
collègues qu'en pensez-vous monsieur le
rapporteur général pour la
commission merci monsieur le Président
cet amement tente à abaisser le plafond
de cotisation minimum de CFE a institué
un dégrffement pour les redevables au
titre des montants trop perçus en 2012 à
contraint le gouvern effectuer une
évaluation préalable avant toute
modification du nouveau plafond bon
euh une partie de l'amendement trouve
satisfaction dans ce qui vient d'être
voté et pour le reste vous
préconisez que l'on aille plus loin que
le le simple règlement d'un problème
d'urgence que auquel nous avons été
confrontés et pour lequel nous avons
essayé de répondre
euh alors bien entendu nous avons une
réflexion engagée 2013 que nous
suggérons en tout cas la commission des
finances du Sénat a envisagé que dans
son programme de travail de début de
l'année 2013 on euh s'appesantisseent un
peu plus sur ce
sujet de l'ensemble des conséquences qui
sont inhérantes à la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle et qui laissent encore
subsister des zones d'incertitude pour
les élus ou bien sans doute des
ajustements nécessaires sur les
mécanismes de substitution et c'est vrai
sur la CFE puisque j'indiquéis tout à
l'heure dans mon propos que nous avions
aussi s'agissant notamment de l'util
ation du chiffre d'affaires comme
élément de référence pour les seuils eu
un questionnement majeur et que je pense
sur ce point nous serons amener à à
réfléchir à une
substitution à ce chiffre d'affaires
d'autres paramètres d'autres indicateurs
plus pertinents je pense à valeur
ajoutée en tout cas il y a une réflexion
à mener là-dessus et dans le même esprit
je pense que les la question posée sur
les les plafonnements de quti minimum
sera également à creuser donc moi j'ai
tendance à vous proposer de de retirer
pour l'instant cet amendement dans
l'attente de cette réflexion conjointe
au sein de la commission des finan et
bon à vous rallier à la partie de
l'amendement voté à l'instant qui répond
déjà par avance à certaines des
questions que vous posiez je sais que ça
ne satisfait pas totalement votre
attente mais si on peut éviter justement
les approximations dans la mise en œuvre
de dispositifs de plafnon ou autre en
ayant emble une réflexion conjointe
efficace dans les deux ou TR mois qui
viennent je pense que nous ferions
avutile donc réglons tout de suite le
problème de l'urgence et réfléchissons
ensemble si vous voulez bien à ce
travail d'affinement nécessaire on est
tous conscients de ça et c'est à ce à
quoi je vous propose de de travailler
ensemble début 2013 pour l'instant je
vous suggère de retirer
l'amendement quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre
défavorable monsieur le Président car il
me semble que cet amendement est
doublement des responsabilisants d'abord
il des responsabilisants en encadrant
les éventuelles hausses qui après tout
sont du ressort des élus locaux pourquoi
ne pas leur faire confiance et les
responsabiliser pour assumer ensuite les
conséquences de ces votes et puis
déresponsabilisant parce que au fond
vous demandez à l'état de se substituer
à des contribuables qui aujourd'hui
s'apprêtent à protester auprès des élus
qui ont augmenté excessivement la
cotisation minimale ça n'est pas la voie
qu'a choisi le gouvernement qui laisse
la possibilité aux collectivités de
revenir sur des choix qu'ils ont pu
faire mais certainement pas de d'aboutir
à ce que l'État paye en lieu et place
finalement de ces collectivités
directement ou indirectement donc il
faut que les élus je le crois nous
sommes tous des élus locaux où l'avons
été un jour il faut que les élus locaux
assument les choix qu'ils font devant
les publics c'estàd les contribuables
qu'il s'apprêtent à solliciter de même
manière que le gouvernement assume très
bien les choix qu'il fait en matière de
fiscalité devant les contribuables qu'il
décident de solliciter avis tout à fait
défavorable
bien monsieur de la vous souhaitez pour
explication de vote vous souhaitez
intervenir oui
écoutez j'entends l'argumentation du
ministre sur
le sur la responsabilité des élus locaux
et et je suis moi-même tout à fait
d'accord avec cette
responsabilité il n'empêche que pour les
entreprises concernées ça a été des
augmentations quand même assez
considérable et on a l'impression que
peut-être certaines profitent des
plafonds ou des possibilités qui leur
sont donné sans aller réfléchir trop
loin en se disant que c'est pas des
sommes considérables mais pour certaines
petites entreprises c'est des sommes
très important donc moi je trouve
dommage bon je je j'ai entendu aussi le
rapporteur général qui lui ouvrait plus
la voix à la discussion et à la
réflexion au sein de de la commission
des finances ce que je serais prêt bien
sûr à à suivre et mais par contre je
vais maintenir l'amendement parce que je
pense que c'est une question qui reste
posée et sur laquelle nous devons nous
prononcer nous devrons nous prononcer
même si je n'ai pas beaucoup de doute
sur l'issue du vote mais je pense que
c'est c'est une réflexion dans laquelle
nous continuons de travailler au sein de
la commission des
finances bien je vous remercie donc il
n'y a pas d'autre explication de
vote donc je mets au voix cet amendement
352 qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 18
B qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté nous en venons après
l'article 18
bis un amendement 246 qui n'est pas
défendu
ensuite un nouvel amendement numéro
170 qui est défendu par Madame
desego merci monsieur le Président oui
cet amendement propose de de proroger de
dispositif transitoire de déduction hors
plafond des rachats de 2 années de
cotisation qui avaient été instauré par
la loi de 2003 portant réforme des des
retraites et et de modifier son champ
d'application biensieurr donc il s'agit
en fait de permettre aux seuls
fonctionnaires à l' activité de
compléter leur versement sur un produit
d'épargne retraite en rente viser
l'article 163 du du code du CGI du Code
Général des Impôts le dispositif serait
plafonné à 10000 € de versement alors
qu'il est aujourd'hui à
13406 €. et et je rajoute que il s'agit
pas d'une réelle perte de recette pour
l'État mais simplement d'un différé
d'imposition les cotisations étant
exonérées euh à l'entrée les pensions
servies taxé à la sortie même chose pour
la la déduction hors plafond des des
rachats d'années de de
cotisation je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur général
oui merci monsieur le
Président le plafond actuel de
déductibilité des cotisations d'épargne
retraite est déjà élevé chers collègues
et pour supprimer une exception au
profit des trois régimes départ une
retraite de la fonction publique et
c'est exception qui pouvait se justifier
je vous l'accorde dans le contexte de
2003 mais la réforme des retraites de
2003 date aujourd'hui de près de 10
ans dès lors vous proposez de
généraliser un régime dérogatoire de
déductibilité fiscale à tous les régimes
d'épargne retraite au demeurant moi
j'observe que le nouveau dispositif ne
bénéficierait en fait qu'aux
fonctionnaires et agents publics
pourquoi privilégier cette seule
catégorie de la
population le Conseil constitutionnel ne
censurerait-il pas une telle rupture
d'égalité c'est une bonne question sans
doute et enfin dans le contexte actuel
des finances publiques un tel dispositif
serait coûteux tout en ne bénéficiant
qu'à un nombre limité de titulaires de
haut revenus le coût serait d'ord de 41
million d'euros donc l'avis de la
commission des finances est dès lors
défavorable même avis même avis même
avis
il n'y a pas d'explication de vote je
vais donc mettre au voix cet amendement
170 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté nous en venons à l'article 18 TER
nous avons deux amendements en
discussion
commune d'abord le 63 qui est présenté
par le président Marini merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues c'est un amendement qui
nous conduit à aborder un domaine un peu
différent de ceux qui ont été vus
jusqu'ici puisqu'il s'agit de
l'industrie musicale et d'y favoriser la
francophonie
et le dispositif du crédit d'impôt en
faveur des entreprises de production
phonographique a déjà été modifié dans
la loi de finances pour 2009 à
l'initiative de notre commission des
finances et ceci
afin
d'éviter pour l'éligibilité au crédit
d'impôt la suppression de la clause de
francophonie dans la définition des
albums de nouveaux talents il s'agit à
présent d'aller plus loin en réservant
le bénéfice du crédit d'impôts aux
seules entreprises produisant plus de la
moitié d'album de nouveaux talents en en
français ou dans une langue régionale en
usage en France en effet l'application
actuelle comporte un point de
fuite si au titre d'un exercice la
production d'album de nouveaux talent en
français n'est pas
majoritaire les albums en français sont
toutefois éligibles au crédit d'impôt et
parallèlement si au titre d'un exercice
la production d'album de nouveaux
talents en français et majoritaire alors
tous les albums de nouveaux talents y
compris dans une langue étrangère
c'est-à-dire en anglais sont éligibles
au crédit d'impôt ma proposition
permettrait de supprimer le premier type
d'éligibilité et inciterai donc les
entreprises du secteur à produire
majoritairement des albums d'expression
française un tel périmètre devrait être
validé sans difficulté par la Commission
européenne je m'en suis assuré du fait
de la faible capacité à l'exportation
des artistes francophones et de
l'absence de discrimination en raison de
la nationalité des artistes ou du lieu
d'établissement des prestataires ces
points avait été retenu par la
commission pour valider notre premier
dispositif en ce domaine en 2006 inciter
l'industrie phonographique à produire
des artistes s'exprimant en français me
semble crucial à l'heure où le recul de
la diversité et de l'exposition des
artistes francophones à la radio pose de
plus en plus de problème le système des
quotas de diffusion francophone à la
radio ne fonctionne en effet pas
correctement notamment parmi les
stations destinées aux jeunes au cours
du prier trimestre 2012 je vous l je
vous livre ce chiffres 245 nouvelles
productions francophones ont été
programmées par les radios contre 298 en
2011 pour la même période en outre 50
nouvelles production francophone
représente les 3/4 des diffusions alors
pour l'ensemble de ces raisons monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je
souhaite vivement que le crédit d'impôt
soit simplifié que les conditions
d'éligibilité soient simplifié et
qu'elle servent mieux la cause de la
Francophonie dans l'univers
musical merci Monsieur
Mar madame est vous présentez le 354
oui c'est un amendement vous l'aurez
remarqué qui est
identique je crois que la défense de la
Francophonie c'est pas seulement
l'action culturelle extérieure de la
France mais c'est aussi veiller à ce que
nos dispositifs en particulier nos
dispositifs fiscaux soient également
incitatifs au développement et à la
promotion de la langue française que
celle-ci puisse être lue puisse être
entendu et exporté à travers
notamment la
musique dans dans le monde entier aussi
c'est le même amendement qu'a très bien
défendu mon collègue Marini donc je ne
rentrerai pas dans les détails
techniques de l'amendement qui vient
donc corriger le dispositif qui a été
retenu à l'Assemblée je vous remercie je
vous remercie chers collègues quel est
l'avis de monsieur le rapporteur général
pour la
Commission et bien monsieur le Président
à nos yeux cet
amendement qui vise à limiter le
bénéfice du crédit d'impôt aux seuls
entre produisant une majorité d'album de
nouveaux talons en français ou en langue
régionale peut se
révéler inquiétante son adoption pour
pour les PME pourquoi et bien parce
qu'actuellement vous savez que les
entreprises de production phonographique
peuvent bénéficier du crédit d'impôt
dans deux cas un si la majorité des
albums produit de nouveaux talent et
d'expression française et de si la
majorité des albums de nouveaux talent
produit est en langue étrangère avec
prise en compte seulement des dépenses
liées à la production des seuls albums
en français ou langue régionale et
l'amendement vise à supprimer ce
deuxième cas pour que seul les les
entreprises produisant plus de la moitié
d'album de nouveaux talents en français
ou langue régionale puissent bénéficier
du crédit
d'impôt alors cette mesure pourrait en
apparence inciter les entreprises à
produire plus d'albums de nouveau talent
d'expression francophone afin de ne pas
être exclus du dispositif et au
contraire en bénéficier plus fortement
puis que tous les albums produits seront
éligibles
toutefois et c'est là notre sujet
d'inquiétude dans c'est une période déjà
difficile cet amendement va exclure du
dispositif les petites entreprises qui
ne peuvent produire que quelques albums
en français et n'ont pas les moyens
d'arriver à la clause des 50
%. cet amendement en définitive
risquerait s'il était adopté de remettre
en cause l'équilibre trouvé en 2009 et
finalement
d'être défavorable à la Francophonie
Infiné c'est-à-dire que les petites
entreprises ne bénéficiant plus du
crédit d'impôt sur les albums en
français pourrai renoncer à les produire
et c'est au regard de cette inquiétude
que nous avions sur les conséquences
d'un tel amendement au niveau des
petites entreprises et il y en a
beaucoup dans le secteur et il y a
beaucoup qui se lancent et qui demain
peut-être hésiterai à le faire c'est au
regard de de cette considération que la
commission des finances s'est prononcée
défavorablement pour cet
amendement quel est la même avis pour le
gouvernement pour les deux
amendements je mets donc oui madame main
de
saill moi je trouve que si on parle
d'inquiétude ce qui a de plus inquiétant
c'est de voir que y compris les petites
entreprises ne sont pas encouragées à
produire des albums en langue française
quand on sait que la langue française
est facilement aussi l'expression dans
nombre de musique et de et de chanson je
vois pas en quoi le dispositif
restreindrait l'obtention de de ce
crédit d'impôt y compris pour les
petites entreprises moi je pense que ce
qui est plus inquiétant c'est
l'envahissement de la langue
anglo-saxonene et au contraire à
contrario le déficite de d'encouragement
et de promotion à travers le dispositif
de l'utilisation de de la langue
française voilà moi c'est une question
un peu de de civilisation de de culture
et puis de diversité aussi culturelle
qui va s'exposer aussi sur les
différentes antennes les chaînes de
télévision et bien sûr à
l'exportation monsieur le Président
Marini oui monsieur le Président en un
mot je suis très surpris de la réponse
que l'on nous
fait
car mettre en avant la cause des PME
c'est ne pas voir qu'elles peuvent
adapter leur comportement nous nous
demandons une chose très simple c'est
que plus de 50 % des albums produits
soient francophones ou breton ou Corse
ou ce qu'on voudra mais qu'il alors
Picard il y en aura moins sans doute
mais
bon non ce n'est pas une question de
sentiment la question et de savoir si un
crédit d'impôt est légitime si son effet
est d'inciter à produire des chansons en
anglais c'est ça la question qui est
posée et c'est la question de la
diversité culturelle c'est notre
université culturelle c'est notre
univers culturel c'est le message que
l'on transmet à nos jeunes et il me
semble
que cet amendement a par ailleurs
l'intérêt de de resserrer une dépense
fiscale j'ai de la peine à comprendre
que le rapporteur général et le ministre
du Budget ne soit pas sensible à cet
argument n'est-ce pas
donc malgré effectivement les arguments
opposés et bien je pense qu'il faut
voter cet amendement et le voter
largement parce que ce n'est pas ou cela
ne devrait pas être une question de
politique
politicienne
rapporteur général tVous
sensible non je je ne peux pas être
sensible monsieur le Président il s'agit
pas du tout de politique politicienne
tout le monde ici dans cet hémicycle a
le souci de la culture et à le souci de
la Francophonie mais chacun a aussi la
préoccupation de veiller à ce que les
petites et moyennes entreprises puissent
trouver des éléments d'incitation à
travers les leviers fiscaux qui sont mis
en place et nous avons sentiment que
aujourd'hui la concentration risque
d'être accentuée si on ne prend pas
garde à préserver quelques outils qui
sont favorables aux petites entreprises
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe madame
main de saill et ben il se passe
qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise en
particulier de petite taille qui produit
30 % d'album francophone bénéficie du
crédit d'impôt que que vise cet
amendement C cet amendement vise à
exiger que si elles n'ont pas 50 %
d'album francophone elles aont zéro
crédit d'impôt aujourd'hui à 30 elles
ont un crédit d'impôt demain avec ce
dispositif si elles n'atteignent pas 50
% ce sera zéro et dès lors c'est un
recul en ce qui concerne l'incitation
fiscale faite au aux petites entreprises
c'est un sujet de préoccupation je crois
et c'est uniquement au regard monsieur
le Président cement on regarde de cette
considération que du champ de la
concurrence sur ce secteur et des
risques pour les PME que nous nous
sommes forgés une opinion et que je
préconise dès lors le rejet de ces
amendements madame
Blandin simplement pour soutenir la
position du rapporteur François Marc le
dispositif de défense de la Francophonie
actuelle est équilibré il est quand même
passé en 4 ans de 3,5 million d'euros à
million d'euros et les récentes
modifications ont fait porter le taux de
20 à 30 % pour les PME et TPE et les
conditions d'accès sont assouplies
puisque maintenant le plafonnement est à
800000 € au lieu de 700000 € en revanche
si on suivait l'amendement tel qu'il n
est proposé par le sénateur marign ou
madame main de sali nous fragiliserions
les petits labels qui qui sont des
producteurs de musique chantée en
français mais aussi dans d'autres
langues mais cette mixité est la
condition de leur survie c'est eux qui
survivent en exportant des disque et de
la musique en partie en français et leur
diversité et leur véhicule d'existence
et c'est le véhicule de la Francophonie
et d'autre part tous ces dispositifs
vont être remis à plat
au travers de la réflexion sur le stop
qui a été donné au Centre national de la
musique je vous rappelle aussi que dans
les comptabilités il arrive qu'on ne
compte en francophone que ce qui est
prononcé en français et que toutes les
musiques non chantées ne sont pas
comptabilisées et que les taux sont
parfois
faussés bien monsieur assouine pour
explication de
vote
oui moi aussi je je
soutiens ce qui nous est proposé et pas
l'amendement je je vois bien puisque on
reçoit et on auditionne tous à peu près
les
mêmes représentants de tel ou tel
secteur notamment culturel je vois bien
où est le sujet il y avait une
inquiétude sur le fait que on puisse
servir de ce crédit impôt euh pour
euh
financer l'ensemble qui pouvait être
ultra majoritaire de ce qui n'était pas
francophone et c'est un on a été alerté
sur le fait que c'était la pratique de
certains euh de certaines boîtes de
production or là ce qui nous est proposé
c'est que ce soit financé ce qu'on
puisse en bénéficier au prorata au
pourcentage de sa production pas pour
financer l'ensemble et donc je crois que
ce serait pervers il y aurait un effet
pervers à vouloir au nom de la
Francophonie mettre un seuil plus haut
50 % qui finalement désavantageraiit
comme l'a dit euh euh la présidente
Blandin euh ceux qui euh sont des
moteurs dans la francophonie et la
promotion de titres francophone mais qui
sont en même temps des moteurs de la
diversité et euh je crois que ce sont
des petits labels qui en patirait pas
seulement c'est vrai mais ce sont des
petits labels qui eux sont très
fragilisés déjà aujourd'hui qui en
patirai aussi et qui eux risqueraient
d'en mourir là où des plus grosses
boîtes pourrai complètement supporter ce
que vous ce que vous dites y compris
parce qu' n pas besoin de ce crédit
d'impôt je n'ai pas d'autres explication
de vote non donc je vais mettre au voix
cet amendement numéro 63 pour lequel et
la Commission et le gouvernement sont
défavorables qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté donc pour le 354 qui est
légèrement différent même
vote même vote il est il n'est pas
adopté nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
séance je vous retrouve demain matin
pour la suite de l'examen de ce texte à
partir de 10h30 sur public sénna bonne
soirée à
tous